Dann solltest du zu drei zählen.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express Ausgabe Nummer 53. Wieder mal ein Thema, was schon lange auf sich hat warten lassen. Ich glaube, ich habe das vor zwei Jahren angekündigt, dass ich das machen wollte. Hallo erstmal, hier ist Tim Pritlove am Mikrofon. Und das Thema heute ist Musik oder um ein bisschen genauer zu werden, das Thema ist Netlabels. Und zu dem Thema habe ich zwei ausgewiesene Experten dabei, wie es ja hier die Regel ist. Und zwar den Timor. Hallo Timor. Vielleicht sollte ich mal dein Mikrofon einschalten. Proben wir es nochmal. Hallo. Wunderbar. Timor Kodal von Pulsar Records. Und dann haben wir noch den Don Ludwig. Hallo. Du bist gleich zu hören. Wunderbar. Von einem anderen Netlabel namens Pentagonic. Richtig. Soweit habe ich keine Fehler gemacht.
Das ist doch schon mal ein ganz guter Ersatz.
Das ist super. Ja, wir sind heute auch ein bisschen experimentell unterwegs, weil die Jungs haben natürlich auch Musik mitgebracht. Das heißt, ich mache hier mal etwas, was ich in letzter Zeit etwas selten getan habe. Trotz alledem habe ich, glaube ich, von, weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau, von wem, aber ich habe schon viel Netlabel-Musik verwendet bei Chaosradio Express. Ist immer ein bisschen schwierig mit Hintergrundmusik. Viele Leute stört das dann auch so, wenn sie in der Straßenbahn hören. Deswegen in letzter Zeit eher weniger. Trotzdem war das immer sehr angenehm, denn Netlabels eröffnen gerade Podcastern und nicht nur Podcastern dann ganz neue Musiknutzungsmöglichkeiten, denn die Musik ist frei. Nicht nur die Gedanken sind frei, sondern auch die Musik ist frei. Aber jetzt werden sich natürlich schon alle fragen, was sind denn eigentlich Netlabels? Naja, ich meine, viele werden wahrscheinlich schon davon gehört haben, aber wir wollen ein bisschen tiefer rein gehen in die Materie heute und auch ein bisschen Musik spielen. Aber vielleicht können wir da jetzt erstmal einsteigen und nochmal so die große Frage stellen, was darf man denn heute unter dem Begriff Netlabel eigentlich genau verstehen?
Ja, die Netlabel, die sind so ein bisschen das Pendant zu den klassischen Labels, die eben CDs oder Vinyl oder sonstige Tonträger vertreiben. Und die Netlabel-Szene, die ist eben dazu übergegangen, dass sie das Internet als Vertriebskanal nutzt und zahlreiche Musiker nutzen die Netlabelwelt, um ihre Musik an den Mann und an die Frau zu bringen. Und das ist so letztendlich der Grund dafür, warum es überhaupt Netlabels gibt. Und als Definition kann man eigentlich so ein bisschen sagen, dass eben manche Netlabel, das ist so die herkömmliche Definition eigentlich, da fällt ein Pulsar Records zum Beispiel ein bisschen raus, aber die halten sich eigentlich an die vorgegebenen Strukturen auch aus der Hardcoverwelt sozusagen. Also die sind eben dazu übergegangen, dass sie diese Release-Form eben auch ins Netz transportiert haben und dass eben zu jeder Release auch mehrere Tracks gehören und ein Cover und Booklets dann meistens in der elektronischen Musikszene eher weniger, weil eben nicht so oft mit Text hantiert wird. Aber das ist so die gängige Definition. Meistens sind die Netlabels auch, also bieten ihr meistens ihr das musikalische Material frei an. Das ist aber auch mittlerweile nicht mehr unbedingt zwingend erforderlich, um die Definition eines Netlabels zu erfüllen, sondern es gibt eben auch mittlerweile einige, die ihre Sachen auch kostenpflichtig zum Download anbieten.
Das heißt, die eigentliche Definition ist schon das Net an der Stelle.
Genau, ich glaube, das vereint alle.
Ein Netlabel unterscheidet sich von einem normalen Label schlicht und ergreifend dadurch, dass es im Netz arbeitet. Aber sind die anderen Labels nicht auch mittlerweile mal irgendwo auch im Netz? Also Homepages haben die schon, oder?
Ziemlich alle Netlabels sind im Prinzip im Netz. Das ist unumgänglich eigentlich. Ich glaube, der Hauptvorteil von einem Netlabel ist tatsächlich, dass man denkt, zumindestens die Freiheit zu haben, alles rauszubringen, was man rausbringen möchte. Also man hat tatsächlich die Freiheit unabhängig von irgendwelchen Zwecken, sei es irgendwie der Musikindustrie oder... Und es gibt auch Netlabels, die halt echt eine ganz kleine Zielgruppe haben, aber dann doch eine Zielgruppe haben. Und somit auch gut funktionieren. Also von daher, dass die Definition im Netz bedeutet im Prinzip auch eine gewisse Definition von Freiheit, die man da hat.
Ja, ich glaube, das ging eher um den Unterschied, was eigentlich jetzt ein Netlabel anders macht, im Vergleich zu einem anderen Label, was eben zusätzlich zu dem Vinylvertrieb z.B. eben auch noch anbietet, dass man auf deren Website dann Musik runterladen kann. Und da, glaube ich, gibt es eben schon einen entscheidenden Unterschied und das ist der, dass eben der Fokus bei den Netlabels ganz eindeutig darauf liegt, dass man die Musik eben originär ins Netz stellt. Das heißt, es ist nicht unbedingt ein Knockout-Kriterium, wenn der Netlabel dazu übergeht, das dann irgendwann auch mal auf Vinyl oder auf CD rauszubringen, aber der ursprüngliche Gedanke ist eben einfach ein anderer, dass man jetzt sich so ein bisschen von den herkömmlichen Vertriebswegen verabschiedet und eben nicht mehr den klassischen Tonträger wählt als Medium, sondern das Format MP3 oder auch Corbis oder wie auch immer.
Vielleicht müssen wir sogar noch ein bisschen weiter ausholen, merke ich gerade, weil ich bemerke in der Diskussion um Musik und insbesondere um freie Musik und noch schlimmer um nicht freie Musik, dass da da wird viel Dampf gequasselt. Also man hat sehr häufig den Eindruck, dass von den Beteiligten dann die Begriffe doch auch mal schnell durcheinander geworfen werden. Dann gibt es dann immer mal ist die GEMA die böse, dann ist es die Musikindustrie. So und der Schwarze Peter wird dann auch immer, wie es einem gerade so passt und welcher Begriff einem zuerst einfällt, von links nach rechts verschoben, sodass man am Ende mal schon gar nicht so genau weiß, wen trifft es dann auch. Und auch viele Sachen, die dann da gefordert werden, habe ich manchmal das Gefühl, trifft dann so die Falschen. Wenn ich mir so Musikern unterhalte, ja die dann immer sagen, naja, wo kommt denn jetzt mal Musik her und so, mal ein Geld her für die Musik und so weiter. Vielleicht sollten wir nochmal kurz deswegen schauen, was ist denn ein Label? Also wenn wir jetzt von Netlabels sprechen, ist es klar, die arbeiten im Netz und die arbeiten für eine oder mit einer Netzgemeinde oder bauen die sich dort auf. Wie arbeitet denn ein Label heutzutage? Also sind die denn zwangsläufig auch in dem Konglomerat Musikindustrie da gefangen?
Also da nochmal darauf eingehend, dass ich glaube, ein Netlabel in dem Sinne hat vor einmal auch den Vorteil, dass sie jetzt zunächst erstmal mit keinen Kosten konfrontiert ist, die ein normales Label dann auch hat. Also wenn man jetzt von einem Plattenrelease spricht oder so, dann hat man zunächst erstmal Vinyls, die man rausbringt, also von einem klassischen oder auch CD-Label, Schallplatten sagt man ja auch, Volksmund. Und das verursacht halt einfach mal Kosten, so irgendwie. Und das sind ja nicht nur die primären Kosten, die Schallplattenkosten selber, sondern der Vertrieb, die Mitarbeiter müssen bezahlt werden und so weiter und so fort.
Wieso sagst du jetzt eigentlich zuerst Vinyl und nicht CDs?
Das ist in der Szene immer noch sehr beliebt für Vinyls.
Das heißt, wenn du von Labels sprichst, sprichst du eigentlich von Labels, die für DJs Musik rausbringen?
Im elektronischen Sinne schon, da wären wir schon im Eingemachten. Die meisten Netlabels bewegen sich leider doch noch im elektronischen Bereich. Also es gibt ja irgendwie so einen elektronischen Musikbereich. Schlager-Netlabels habe ich noch nicht gesehen. Da gab es noch nicht so ein Zitat im Wikipedia-Eintrag. Das ist auch mit der Grund, warum es tatsächlich sehr viele Netlabels auch im elektronischen Bereich gibt, weil die Musikproduktion tatsächlich am Computer immer noch oder beziehungsweise so ist, dass es ja tatsächlich einfacher ist. Also das wäre glaube ich ein Grund, warum es so eine gewisse Faszination gibt von Netlabels, dass man mit wenig Mitteln plötzlich Musik publizieren kann, die dann im Internet bereitstellen kann.
Okay, aber ein Label allgemein betrachtet ist ja eigentlich nichts weiter als eine Klammer. Also die einfach verschiedene Künstler oder sonstige Kultur oder sonst wie tätige Menschen irgendwie zusammenfasst. Gibt es jetzt auch nicht nur im Musikbereich. Und wenn man das dann davon ableitet, dann ist eben die Tätigkeit, die dann eigentlich ein Netlabel auch vollzieht, eigentlich relativ ähnlich auch derer, die ein klassisches Plattenlabel eben für die Musiker initiiert. Also es geht darum...
Und was ist das genau?
Was ist diese Tätigkeit? Da geht es eben darum, dass man mit, wenn man ein Label ins Leben ruft, egal in welchem Bereich man sich da betätigen will, dann überlegt man sich ja meistens vorher, wo will ich hin? Also man versucht sich vielleicht irgendwie stilistisch oder thematisch in irgendeine Richtung zu entwickeln und scharrt dann eben die entsprechenden Musiker oder eben anders sonst wie tätige Künstler um sich, von denen man eben der Meinung ist, dass deren Material irgendwie in die Welt gehört und andererseits eben auch zu dem Label passt, das man ins Leben gerufen hat. Also insofern sind, glaube ich, die Netlabel auch gar nicht so...
Was Besonderes erst mal.
Nö, eigentlich so vom Prinzip her.
Das war Chaosradio Express 53. Okay, also das heißt, es ist eigentlich mehr eine Marke. Kann man das so sagen? Ja, das heißt, man schafft so einen Begriff und man assoziiert einen gewissen Stil, ein gewisses Händchen damit und versucht Leute quasi über diese gemeinsame Marke für eine bestimmte Musikart oder einen bestimmten Katalog von Musik zu gewinnen.
So ist es. Sonst wäre es ja noch für den Hörer noch schwieriger, sich aus dem Wust der ganzen angebotenen Musik eben einfach auch diejenige rauszusuchen, von der man irgendwie der Meinung ist, dass sie einfach gut ist. Also insofern ist das Label einfach, was wie der Name Label auch schon sagt, das ist halt einfach ein riesiges Konglomerat an unterschiedlichster Musik. Und auf ein paar Highlights dieser Musik wird dann eben einfach ein Label, also ein Etikett draufgestempelt und dann weiß der Hörer ungefähr auch, okay, da steht jetzt Pentagonik drauf, das heißt, es steht für minimal angehauchten Club-Sound oder steht irgendwas anderes drauf, dann ist es dann eben, bedient es eher die Klientel, die das ganz gerne zuhause zum Einschlafen hört, ambient oder elektro oder das gibt ja auch so viele elektronische Musikrichtungen. Wie gesagt, im Netlabel-Bereich muss man schon dem Rechnung tragen, dass es sich eben überwiegend in der elektronischen Musikszene beheimatet fühlt, weil da einfach auch so ein bisschen die Ursprünge liegen. Ich denke, in den nächsten Jahren wird sich das auf jeden Fall ein bisschen auflösen und ich hoffe, dass dann eben auch analoge Musikrichtungen noch einen Stärken Einfluss halten.
Das überrascht mich nicht. Ich denke, wir sind ja auch noch am Anfang der Entwicklung, um da vielleicht schon mal in einer Konklusion dieses Gesprächs hier vorauszugreifen. Aber das war ja, sagen wir mal, zum Beispiel bei der Wikipedia nicht anders. Die haben irgendwie angefangen und von den ersten 50.000 Artikeln drehten sich bestimmt die Hälfte um Informatik-Themen. Selbstverständlich ist das, was da nahe liegt, als erstes auch mit dabei. Und natürlich, ich weiß nicht, also mit dieser elektronischen Musik ist ja auch gleichzeitig verbunden. Das sind dann halt Leute, die benutzen eben Computer. Und weil sie die haben, sind sie natürlich auch dem Netz näher und sind auch generell natürlich neuen Produktionsmethoden näher aufgeschlossen und so weiter und so weiter. Die ganze Technogeneration eigentlich, die sich so in den 90er Jahren aufgemacht hat, trägt ja eigentlich die ganze Zukunft immer so schön vor sich her auf so einem Schild. Hier, Love Parade, wir sind anders.
Zu dem Thema Marke kann man sicherlich nochmal sagen, dass natürlich für den End-User, also für den Zuhörer der Musik, dass auf jeden Fall super, also auf jeden Fall sehr wichtig ist, einzuschränken, ungefähr den Sound irgendwie herauszufinden sozusagen und zu sagen, irgendwie da will ich nochmal hin oder das Netlabel kenn ich und da würde ich mir dann nochmal Dinge runterladen, ähnlich wie in der realen Welt, so wie dass ich mir eine Platte kaufe, weil genau ich schon mal ein paar Platten von der Band oder von dem Label kannte. Aber für den Musiker ist es vor allem auch ein Dreh- und Angelpunkt und ein Ansprechpartner, das Label und vor allem auch ein Vertriebsweg. Also wir haben es jetzt bei Pentagonik so, dass jeder User eine einzelne Seite hat. Da gibt es dann rechts die Möglichkeit, die Reviews, also wo er dann erwähnt wurde, sozusagen mit aufzuführen und so und das ist so ein kleiner MySpace-Account dann für den Künstler. Also von daher, aus der Sicht des Künstlers ist es glaube ich auch sehr wichtig, dass hat die Funktion des Labels halt auch eine Berechtigung.
Das heißt, ihr habt da sozusagen auch schon Ansätze von Social-Networking quasi mit drin?
Würde ich nicht sagen, also jetzt nicht von der Software her, so irgendwie, also Social-Networking.
Ja klar, aber ich meine, es ergibt sich ja automatisch. Also Leute melden sich an, sind da, haben eine Präsenz und man kann dann sozusagen innerhalb einer Website auch wirken und sich darstellen. Das ist ja eigentlich auch dieser Erfolg von MySpace, so der zum Beispiel, was mein Eindruck ist, vielleicht kann man das ja mal kurz vorziehen, so MySpace ist extrem missverstanden im Computer-Bereich, ja, weil da wird das halt einfach nur so als yet another Community, wo man seine Daten hinterlassen abgesehen hat und damit ist das Ding dann irgendwie abgefeiert. Aber im Musikbereich hat MySpace ja, gut, schwieriges Wort, Revolution, will ich jetzt vielleicht nicht sagen, aber das hat doch schon einige Schockwellen ausgesendet, oder? Liege ich da falsch?
Also ich kann von MySpace leider nur sagen, dass ich da regelmäßig drauf muss, leider. Wir kriegen halt diverse Anfragen von Labels oder auch von einzelnen Musikern, die musikalisch eher grenzwertig sind. Gerade die Masse macht es halt. Wir hatten bisher noch wunderbar gut funktionierende Vertriebswege über das klassische Medium-Mail, vielleicht der eine oder andere kennt es noch, oder Telefon, oder man trifft sich auch nochmal vielleicht echt. Und da geht es mir vor allem auch darum, dass die Leute sich dann auch mehr treffen. Aber MySpace funktioniert natürlich auf jeden Fall, wenn man die Leute ansprechen kann.
Funktioniert halt genau in erster Linie deswegen auch, weil es so riesengroß geworden ist. Und dadurch eben viele Kontakte man da einfach herstellen kann zu Leuten, die sonst vielleicht nicht so exponiert im Netz vertreten sind. Und dann schafft man es dann eben direkt über MySpace, dann eben das Account des jeweiligen Künstlers zu finden und ihnen dann zu kontaktieren. Wobei ich finde, also dieser MySpace-Hype, der ist bis zum gewissen Grad sicherlich hat ja auch eine Berechtigung. Andererseits ist es ja so, dass gerade bei bekannteren Musikern ist es so, erstens mal gucken, die schon fast gar nicht mehr rein, weil die sowieso überwiegend zugespammt werden von allen möglichen anderen Künstlern, die eigentlich MySpace dann wirklich nur noch dafür benutzen, um ja auf ihre Releases aufmerksam zu machen. Oder schlimmer noch, dann wirklich komplett sinnfremde Spam-Geschichten dann in meinem Kommentarbereich landen oder so. Also ich glaube, das ist auf jeden Fall ein sehr nützliches Tool, was glaube ich einerseits eben durch die Größe auch so nützlich ist, andererseits auch an der Größe sehr krankt. Also da sehe ich dann zum Beispiel auch so ein bisschen dann wiederum in Abgrenzung dazu, die Daseinsberechtigung vom Pulsaren, wo das Ganze dann eben ein bisschen kleiner gestrickt ist und sich auch wirklich auf eine bestimmte Zielgruppe, nämlich die elektronische Musikgruppe, Zielgruppe dann beschränkt und das auch einen stärkeren regionalen Aspekt hat.
Wir reden gleich darüber, vielleicht noch kurz zum Beispiel, aber meine Wahrnehmung, dass das schon so ein bisschen die Visitenkartenbörse im Musikbereich geworden ist, die stimmt, ja, weil ich habe gesehen, also Musiker, DJ, also auch so Musiker, die ich schon längere Zeit kenne, die eigentlich auch mit Internet alle möglichen Berührungsprobleme hatten, alle sind dann irgendwann dazu übergegangen, dort zumindest mal einen Account zu machen, vielleicht auch gleich mehrere, wenn sie noch unter verschiedenen Pseudonymen arbeiten, einfach um so einen Ort zu haben, wo sie jetzt ohne große Arbeit und Kosten zu haben ihren Kram präsentieren können. Und das mit diesem kleinen Flashplayer da, der einfach sofort Musik abspielt, das hat natürlich dann auch seine Wirkung. Gut, aber jetzt habt ihr ja, es ist schon angedeutet, ihr sprecht eine andere Community an. Also ihr seid jetzt nicht der Ort, wo alle hinkommen sollen, sondern ihr habt eigene Zielgruppen. Vielleicht reden wir mal so ein bisschen über eure beiden Projekte selber. Also Pulsar-Records und Pentagonik, vielleicht könnt ihr das mal so vorstellen, was eure Vorstellung davon ist, worum es sich dabei wirklich handelt.
Zuerst mal Don, weil ich glaube, Pentagonik entspricht eher so dem klassischen Bild eines Netlabels.
Okay, könnte man, ja. Also das Ganze ist 2005 entstanden, also da fiel mir eigentlich ein bisschen davor schon, also offizieller Release oder Launch unserer ersten Party war im März 2005 in der alten Moschee in Kreuzberg und die ist extrem gut auch besucht worden, wir hatten da ziemlich viel geflayert, haben grundsätzlich zwei Zielgruppen, das sind, kann man vielleicht so sagen, also die aus der Offline-Welt und die aus der Online-Welt. Das ist auch so ein bisschen unser Konzept, gerade diese beiden zu verbinden. Von den Leuten, die Pentagonik machen, waren es im Anfang tatsächlich fünf Leute, witzigerweise fünf Leute, die sich mit unterschiedlichen Themen beschäftigt haben. Wir hatten diverse Musiker, die ihre Releases rausbringen wollten, wir hatten Leute, die im Veranstaltungsbereich tätig waren, meine Wenigkeit, ich mache die Grafik und kümmere mich um Presse und so eine Geschichte. Wir hatten aus unterschiedlichen Bereichen Interessengebiete, die wir alle gebündelt haben in dieses Projekt, mit dem entsprechenden Konzept.
Und vereint durch die Liebe zur Musik und wahrscheinlich auf Partys alle über die Zeit kennengelernt.
Genau, aber es war noch ein bisschen mehr, gerade eben nicht nur die Party und eben nicht nur die Online-Releases, sondern gerade durch das Verbinden dieser beiden Bereiche was Neues schaffen. Da haben sich viele Sachen nicht realisiert oder realisieren können, die wir realisieren wollten. In anderer Form, hier und da und so. Und das sind im Prinzip so die beiden Bereiche, die wir angesprochen haben. Jetzt haben wir 19. Release rausgebracht und haben ziemlich schnell am Anfang angefangen, sogenannte Release-Partys zu machen. Die waren damals im Watergate, im Jahr 2005. Und da haben wir dann dieses Release gefeiert. Da gab es einen Flyer, der das Cover hatte, also das Cover war auch gleichzeitig das Release-Cover. So wollten wir dann darauf hinweisen. Und ja, das ist halt sehr gut angekommen, weil wir dann auf der einen Seite die Leute auch ansprechen konnten im Webbereich. Hier geht mal in den Club und die Club-Leute könnten wir darauf ansprechen. Und da zu dem Zeitpunkt war Myspace noch nicht so der Oberhype, was eigentlich auch ganz gut ist. Also, Myspace ist super, das wollte ich auch nochmal bemerken. Und ja, das hat sich halt so weiterentwickelt und man kann eigentlich so sagen, dass es so zwei Communities gibt, die für sich genommen auch immer voneinander gelernt haben.
Okay, und jetzt hast du gesagt, das neunzete Release in zwei Jahren, das klingt so wie, alle zwei Monate kommt mal was raus.
Also es gibt Netlabels, die haben weitaus mehr, ich kenne wenige Netlabels, die weniger haben in der Zeit. Wir haben uns da auch ziemlich viel Zeit gelassen.
Und der Release muss man mir jetzt so was vorstellen wie ein Album.
Genau.
Das ist dann auch nur ein Künstler oder sind das Compilations?
In der Regel ist es ein Künstler, den wir da präsentieren mit vier Tracks. Die gehen von vier bis acht Minuten circa. Und das ist nichts anderes als eine Platte im Prinzip, wie man sich das vorstellt, bloß dass man sich das Cover runterladen kann und die mp3s oder alles zusammen in einem Zipferl. So und da kann man sich das dann runterladen, frei. Also das heißt, alle Releases sind frei erhältlich. Laufen da Creative Commons-License, wenn wir später nochmal vielleicht ein bisschen eingehen. Ja, genau und es gibt, wenn du jetzt irgendwie vielleicht den Community-Charakter ansprechen möchtest, gibt es die Möglichkeit, dass die Personen auch direkt Kommentare zu dem Release hinzufügen können, was zum Teil aus aller Welt passiert. Das ist im Prinzip das, was MySpace auch ausmacht.
Da habt ihr dann eine spezielle Webseite dafür oder fahrt ihr dann ein normales Blog?
Wir haben ein selbstentwickeltes CMS damals, also der DR Ötzi oder SQ, der ist selber auch Produzent und Programmierer. Und ich als Grafiker, wir haben zusammen das Datenbanksystem entwickelt. Und das ist im Prinzip vielleicht interessiert den ein oder anderen auch. Das ist eine Kombination aus Kontaktverwaltung und aus Party-Posting, Party-Eintragetool und Verwaltung der MP3s im Prinzip. Das ist also eher von uns entwickelt. Wir wollten es irgendwann vielleicht mal auch als freie Software anbieten. Das könnte vielleicht den ein oder anderen Netlabel auch interessieren. Und damit haben wir die Möglichkeit, relativ schnell auch Releases online zu schalten. Und Statistiken abzufragen.
Und die Zielgruppe von dieser Musik sind DJs? Kann man das so sagen?
Also inzwischen sind es tatsächlich auch DJs, weil die MP3s auch in aller Welt gespielt werden. Aber ich würde sagen, ja, DJs und...
Aber nicht die DJs, die jetzt wirklich Schellack anfordern. Also es gibt das nicht in Vinyl.
Es gibt es noch nicht in Vinyl. Also wir wollen demnächst, eventuell, das kann ich später vielleicht noch mal erwähnen, auch planen, ein Vinyl an der Schallplatte herauszubringen. Also abgespielt werden können diese MP3s, zum Beispiel ein feines Cratch. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das jetzt erwähnen kannst.
Über Technik kann man hier generell reden.
Dann kann Timor vielleicht noch ein bisschen besser.
Ich notiere mir das mal kurz mit dem feinen Cratch, weil ich glaube, das ist nochmal so eine ganz eigene Abteilung. Also es gibt immer mehr DJs, die halt auch selber digital abspielen. Das ist ja der eigentliche Trend, der dahinter steht. Also Vinyl und auch CDs, das gab es ja eine Weile. Ich weiß nicht, die CDs haben nie so richtig ihren Durchbruch gefeiert. Es gab manche, die machen nur CDs, so im Ambient-Bereich, weil das natürlich viel verbreitet da.
So viel schon vorweg. Es gibt eine Möglichkeit, MP3s auch abzuspielen, wie eine normale Platte.
Genau, das ist das, was Vinyl-Scritch macht. Das wird auch benutzt, ja?
Ja, es wird regelmäßig auch benutzt, auch auf unseren Netlag-Partys. Mehr oder weniger ist es einfach eine Synchronisation einer vorhandenen Platte, wo gar nichts drauf ist, und einem Computer, wo die MP3s draufliegen. Da ist noch ein Gerät dazwischen geschaltet. Und das Ganze wird dann automatisch synchronisiert.
Ja, also Final Scratch ist wirklich ein fantastisches Stück Software. Es gibt da sogar noch eine CCC-relevante Verbindung dahinter, weil die erste Beta-Version davon, also die allererste Version, die das gemacht hat, also wo diese Idee geboren wurde, wo das das erste Mal implementiert wurde, die lief auf einem Computer, der heute überhaupt nicht populär ist, der B-Box, bevor das also seinen Weg sozusagen... Wie heißt die Firma, die das jetzt aufgekauft hat?
Native Instruments.
Native Instruments, genau.
Das heißt ja auch nicht mehr Final Scratch, sondern heißt mittlerweile Traktor Scratch. Also ursprünglich hatten die ja noch einen Partner, von dem sie sich dann gelöst haben, Stanton, und die haben jetzt eine eigene Entwicklung angestoßen. Und die letzte Version von der Hardware ist eben auch eine komplette Entwicklung von Native Instruments jetzt mittlerweile. Also ohne den Partner Stanton, der am Anfang noch mit dabei war und die Hardware bereitgestellt hat.
Verstehe. Mittlerweile haben sie sozusagen alle verstanden, wie es funktioniert.
Genau. Es gibt ja mittlerweile auch zahlreiche Konkurrenzprodukte. Das sollten wir ja wahrscheinlich auch nennen. Das ist zwar kein öffentlich-rechtlicher Podcast, aber es gibt zum Beispiel... M-Audio-Talk ist zum Beispiel eine Alternative. Dann gibt es auch natürlich Serato von Rain. Es gibt auch zahlreiche Lösungen, die komplett auf eine eigene Hardware verzichten. Das heißt, da kann man dann auch die eigene Soundkarte benutzen, wenn man denn schon eine hat. Das ist zum Beispiel Virtual DJ. Das ist eine französische Firma, hat sich nicht so wirklich durchgesetzt. Es gibt eine Software, die ganz gut auch läuft. Habe ich auch selber schon getestet und war eigentlich relativ zufrieden. Das ist Mixed Vibes, heißt das. Da kann man dann sozusagen die Software besorgen, ohne dass man extra noch mal eine Hardware dazu braucht.
Wie das bei dem Traktor der Fall ist.
Wie das bei Traktor oder bei Torque oder bei Serato der Fall ist.
Aber man braucht immer diese Schallplatte, oder?
Die Timecode-Venues braucht man immer. Die sind auch nicht untereinander kompatibel, dummerweise auch noch.
Okay, das sollte man vielleicht noch kurz erklären. Jetzt sind wir schon da, jetzt müssen wir das auch machen. Also das coole ist, man hat im Prinzip einen normalen MP3-Player auf seinem Rechner. Bloß welche Stelle dieses MP3s konkret in welcher Geschwindigkeit abgespielt wird, das steuert man mit einer richtigen Schallplatte auf einem richtigen Turn-Table.
Total anachronistisch eigentlich auch.
Ja, aber ein super User Interface. Ich fand das großartig. Und jetzt kann ich noch mal sagen, was ich vorhin sagen wollte. Also die allererste Implementierung von diesem Prinzip, die wurde der Öffentlichkeit auf dem ersten Chaos-Communication-Camp 1999 vorgestellt. Irgendeinem Zelt. Ich habe es da leider nicht live gesehen, aber ich hatte kurz vorher schon von der Software gehört. Das war dann irgendwie da.
Und in der letzten Reihe saß wahrscheinlich irgendeiner von Stanton, hat fleißig mitgeschrieben.
Das waren holländische Hacker aus unserem Umfeld. Vierte Jungs, die das gemacht haben. Das ist dann lange Geschichte, dann halt irgendwie bei Native Instruments gelandet. Wie auch immer. Ich fand das von Anfang an, hatte das einfach einen extrem hohen Hack-Value, weil man dann einfach schafft, so diese neue Zeit und die alte Zeit auf eine Art und Weise miteinander zu verbinden. Freund von mir hat auch so was Ähnliches rumgehackert, aber erst diese Idee mit diesem Timecode auf der Platte, also das, wenn man die Nadel irgendwo aufsetzt, dass in dem Moment Frequenzen halt so gespielt werden, dass der Rechner mehr oder weniger sofort feststellen kann, wo befindet er sich auf der Platte, in welche Richtung bewegt sich diese Platte und wie schnell. Also im Prinzip genau das, was man eben haben muss. Na gut, machen wir die Klappe mal wieder zu. Also wir sehen, auch wenn man digital Musik distributiert, es gibt die Möglichkeit, das auch auf Partys, wo Vinyl eingesetzt wird, noch zu machen, indem man halt noch einen Rechner mit dabei hat, der spezielle Software fährt. Aber so, also trotzdem würde ich doch mal sagen, ist dieser Vinyl-Markt, wo der DJ noch in den Plattenladen läuft und der Netlabel-Markt, wo man sich so das MP3-File holt, das sind doch schon noch mal zwei separate Welten, oder?
Das sind zwei unterschiedliche Welten und für viele Netlabels auch immer so ein Ziel zurzeit noch, oder beziehungsweise generell für Musiker wahrscheinlich noch ein Ziel, irgendwann mal das schwarze Gold in der Hand zu haben.
Deswegen würdet ihr das auch ganz gerne mal machen.
Es wird wahrscheinlich auch kommen. Es gibt halt immer eine gewisse Entwicklung von der Musik, von am Anfang oder wann man angefangen hat. Wir haben zumindest versucht, unsere Qualität immer zu steigern. Dadurch, dass wir auch im Prinzip grundsätzlich andere auch immer abgelehnt, also andere Release-Anfragen abgelehnt haben, unter anderem von MySpace. Das kann ich vielleicht auch allen Netlabels immer nur weitergeben, dass man grundsätzlich nicht alles rausbringen muss, nur weil man die Möglichkeit hat, tatsächlich was rauszubringen. Sondern man sollte tatsächlich zu dem stehen, wenn sie natürlich selber das Problem haben, da mit klarzukommen. Das ist etwas anderes oder so.
Okay, damit wir uns mal ein Bild davon machen, was ihr für eine Musik spielt. Welches von diesen fünf soll ich jetzt hier mal anklicken?
Ich spiele auch mal gleich das erste.
Gleich mal das erste Mal abspielen. Vielleicht kannst du vorher noch ein paar Töne dazu sagen, dann hören wir da mal kurz rein.
Das ist von Lukas Lehmann, der ist Anfang des Jahres dabei. Der kommt aus Darmstadt. Er ist auch einer der Anwärter für das schwarze Gold.
Oh, ein Anwärter für das schwarze Gold. Dann hören wir doch mal rein, wie das so klingt. Das's für. Tschüss Ja, das erinnert mich ja schon ein bisschen an Popcorn hier. Gute alte 70er Jahre. Ist das jetzt so typisch für euch?
Wir gehen definitiv so in die Richtung Club-Sound, wobei das vielleicht jetzt gerade nicht ganz so typisch ist.
Nicht ganz so clubby war.
Ja, aber wir können ja später nochmal einen anderen Track anspielen. Aber es geht vor allem halt auch darum, es gibt halt sehr viele Labels, die einen sehr verkopften Sound haben, der auch persönlich mir auch super gut gefällt. Ich höre auch sehr viel Ambience zum Beispiel. Und das funktioniert aber auch in den Clubs nicht. Wie gesagt, da schlafen Leute halt ein.
Und dich geht es ums Tanzen.
Ja, im Club geht es schon ums Tanzen. Und auf wann warst du im Club?
Saunaclub?
Chaoscomputer-Club hat eine hohe Quote an Konsumtionen, elektronischer Musik auf jeden Fall.
Also ich will sagen, das war halt so ein bisschen unser Anspruch, tanzbare Musik zu machen und uns vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu distanzieren von den herkömmlichen Netlabels, weil es ja doch, man schätzt, ungefähr über 1000 Netlabels gibt. Echt?
1000? Das wäre fast noch eine Frage gewesen. Oh, Hammer. Da fragt man sich, ob es überhaupt die passende Zielgruppe dazu gibt.
Ja, es gibt also eine endlos große Anzahl von Zielgruppen. Von ganz vielen kleinen Zielgruppen. Kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass es für nur...
Was gibt es denn noch außer DJs? Da waren wir so ein bisschen hängen geblieben. Also ihr machte Musik, jetzt hast du gesagt, okay, jetzt nach einiger Zeit kommen dann auch die DJs dazu. Wer war es denn dann vorher? War das reine Musikliebhaber oder...
Also Zielgruppe am Anfang sind immer Freunde. Weil man noch nicht bekannt ist und dann spricht sich das rum und dann wird Musik runtergeladen und dann kann man ja ungefähr sehen, woher die Musik kommt. Ich würde fast sagen, ja, am Anfang waren es tatsächlich Musikliebhaber aus der ganzen Welt. Man kriegt dann lustige Anfragen von einem Typen aus der Ukraine, einem Hinterdorf, der irgendwie fragt, ob er es auf eine Privatparty spielen kann. Gerne. Das macht dann auch irgendwie Spaß. Oder ein Radio aus Frankreich, wo das plötzlich gespielt wird.
Aber bis dahin ist es ja alles nur Arbeit. Ich meine, über zwei Jahre lang die Arbeit eines Labels durchzuziehen und das dann frei zur Verfügung zu stellen, ist da jetzt in irgendeiner Form an irgendeiner Stelle auch schon ein Geldfluss mit dabei oder?
Ne, noch zurzeit nicht. Serverkosten haben wir viel, ne, aber...
Okay, also es gibt einen Geldfluss von euch weg.
Einen Geldabfluss sozusagen, ja, ein negativer Geldfluss, wenn man es so nennt. Aber durch die Partys kommt auch Geld wieder rein und so. Das war ungefähr auf Null. Also fragen mich natürlich auch viele, warum machst du das überhaupt? Irgendwie über einen längeren Zeit.
Kann man die Musik bei euch auch kaufen?
Kann man nicht, nee. Also irgendwie, weil wir bis jetzt eher von dem Gedanken überzeugt waren, dass Musik frei sein sollte erst mal. Diese Musik, die wir jetzt anbieten, soll zunächst erst mal frei sein. Und der nächste Schritt wäre bei uns dann tatsächlich entweder die Distribution über Beatport, dass man bestimmte Tracks auch anbietet. Beatport ist ein Sammelsurium für den Verkauf von digitaler, also digitale Musik wird dort vertrieben sozusagen. Man kann dort Musik vertreiben. Weißt du gerade, wer es tut?
Das hat auch mittlerweile Native Instruments. Vielleicht glaubst du sogar, glaube ich, auch von Anfang an eine Entwicklung von Native Instruments gewesen.
Ach, das ist dieser Store, der quasi in die Software mit eingebaut ist.
Ich glaube Richie Horton, der hat da auch ganz mächtig seine Finger mit im Spiel. Jedenfalls ist das eine internationale Plattform, bei der man als Musikkonsument, ähnlich wie bei iTunes oder so, Musik per Mausklick herunterladen kann. Krankt ein bisschen in Deutschland noch die Verbreitung darin, dass ausschließlich über Kreditkarteninformationen abgewickelt wird, was natürlich nicht unbedingt für den deutschen Markt so die super Grundvoraussetzung ist, weil doch in Deutschland viele gerne mit Lastschrift oder sonst irgendwie bezahlen. Aber durchaus ein interessantes Tool und da kann man eben kostenpflichtig...
Das ist sozusagen ein Store für DJs. Ich habe das noch mal gesehen, das ist so mit allen möglichen Metadaten, die man sonst nie interessant finden würde, was weiß ich, Beat per Minute und wahrscheinlich eine relativ ausgefeilte Definition des Genres etc.
Da gibt es dann auch keine MP3s übrigens, sondern eben wirklich kompressionsfreie W oder Ives zum Beispiel oder whatever.
Und das wäre dann auch noch ein Weg für euch sozusagen, das dort zu bieten?
Zum einen das und zum anderen die Distribution über die Platte, wobei man über Platte nicht wirklich Geld mitmachen kann, also zunächst nicht heute.
Jedenfalls nicht in den Auflagen.
Nicht in der Größe.
Also Pulsar Records macht das ja auch, die Distribution über Beatport zum Beispiel, das ist dann aber nicht, also ich hab's vorgezogen, das komplett zu trennen. Es gibt eben einmal das Netlabel und die NetAudio Community Pulsar Records. Da ist grundsätzlich immer alles kostenlos und es gibt einen Spin-off-Label, das nennt sich Little Green Man. Und das ist eben so ein Label, das in Zukunft eben auch plant.
Jetzt können wir auch gleich mal da einsteigen. Jetzt hat ja Don relativ ausführlich schon erläutert, was Pentagonik bisher so, getrieben hat und was sie getrieben hat, das zu tun. Wie sieht das jetzt bei deinem Projekt aus?
Ja, ich versuche das jetzt mal so ein bisschen in Abgrenzung zu Pentagonik und auch zu den anderen Netlabeln mal zu beschreiben, weil Pulsar Records da schon, glaube ich, so ein bisschen bis zum gewissen Grad eine Sonderstellung einnimmt. Es gibt bei Pulsar Records, also zunächst mal vorweg gesagt, es gibt seit 2004, also Anfang 2004 ist das Ganze ins Leben gerufen worden. Es war eigentlich ein Ein-Mann-Projekt, so ein bisschen gestartet. Also ich hatte ein paar Musiker um mich herum gescharrt, für die sollte das Ganze eigentlich so eine kleine Präsentationsplattform werden. Hab dann, ja durch ein paar Zufälle kamen dann eben andere Leute auch darauf und fanden das interessant und wollten sich dann da auch repräsentiert wissen. Und da ich so ein bisschen aus der IT-Entwickler- und Programmiererecke komme, hat sich das dann irgendwann für mich angeboten, hab ich mir gedacht, okay, wenn es da ein Interesse für gibt, von anderen Artists sich eben im Netz zu präsentieren und die Musik da anzubieten, dann biete ich das an, hab dann so ein Flash-Projekt zunächst, das war also der erste Pulsar, war komplett rein auf Flash basiert und auch wirklich noch eine ganz überschaubare Anzahl an Musikern, die da eben ihre Tracks angeboten haben. Und das hat sich dann so ein bisschen verselbstständigt, es kam immer mehr dazu.
Also es war zunächst einmal eigentlich mehr so eine Download-Plattform.
Genau, für eine ganz kleine Handvoll.
So ein Ort, wo so Files rumlagen.
Genau. Wurde aber, wie gesagt, ganz gut angenommen und es wollten eben vor allem Musiker da auch noch mit dazu stoßen und dann habe ich das Ganze irgendwann geöffnet für alle. Und damit war dann eigentlich so auch die Entwicklung von der Plattform dann vorgegeben, die sich dann jetzt so im Laufe der Zeit entwickelt hat. Also es geht eigentlich darum, dass jeder sich da anmelden kann und seine Musik erstmal online stellen kann. Also es ist jetzt im Unterschied zu den anderen Netlabeln, ist es so, dass es eben keine Redaktion gibt, die sagt, das ist gut, das ist nicht gut, das wird veröffentlicht und das landet im Papierkorb, sondern es ist so, dass erstmal alles reingestellt werden darf. Das hat am Anfang auch so funktioniert, dass da gar keine weitere Auswahl auch erfolgt ist. Also die Sachen, die wurden dann einfach da online gestellt und dann lagen sie da auf der Plattform und jeder konnte sich das entweder runterladen oder hat es bleiben gelassen, wenn es ihm nicht gefallen hat. Bis dann irgendwann, dass eben einfach zu viel wurde und jeden Tag dann eben paar Tracks gekommen sind und irgendwann musste man sich dann schon, auch wenn man keine Redaktion hat aufgrund personeller Unterbesetzung, muss man sich dann überlegen, wie man eben trotzdem so einen gewissen Qualitätsanspruch dann noch wagt und dann bin ich dazu übergegangen, da so eine kleine Barriere einzubauen. Das heißt, es kann jetzt jeder trotzdem immer noch seinen Track hochladen und auch kostenlosen Web-Space benutzen, zum Beispiel auf dem Server, aber es ist so, dass es eine Schonfrist gibt von zwei Wochen und in dieser Zeit muss sich der Track bewähren und das tut er, indem er ausreichend positive Bewertungen von den anderen Nutzern der Plattform sammelt. Also es gibt dann sozusagen einen Stichtag, der liegt zwei Wochen nach dem ersten Einstellen des Tracks und dann wird entschieden, der hat genug positive Bewertungen gesammelt, der kommt in den Release-Pool und die anderen, die werden dann nicht so ganz weggeschmissen, aber landen in den B-Ware-Pool und so hat dann eben der Nutzer, der auf die Plattform kommt, schon so eine gewisse Vorauswahl, die dann eben sicherstellt, dass jetzt nicht der allerletzte Ramsch oder unfertige Tracks oder sonst irgendwas.
Also es ist eigentlich so eine Art vollautomatisiertes Netlabel.
Genau, also die Redaktion wird von den Nutzern selber übernommen und dadurch, daraus hat sich eben eigentlich auch eine sehr innige Beziehung zwischen den Musikern entwickelt, die eben eben die Tracks untereinander bewerten und also in einem kommunikativen Austausch auch dann eben betreiben und das hat auch die Community dann so auf lange Sicht dann auch recht groß und vor allem auch in sich.
Was heißt denn groß? Wie viele Leute sind denn da so. Also im Vergleich zu MySpace ist natürlich... Ne, ich meine groß ist relativ, klar, aber wie groß, was muss man sich das vorstellen?
Es sind jetzt 3500 Benutzer insgesamt und davon ungefähr 1200 Musiker bundesweit. Also mit einem starken Fokus auf die...
Nein, ich meine 1200 Leute muss man erst mal zusammenkriegen.
Ne, ich glaube auch in der Net-Audio-Szene ist Pulsar Records dann doch schon eines der größeren Projekte, kann man auf jeden Fall so sehen.
1200 Musiker und der Rest? Hörer.
Hörer. Am Anfang war das Verhältnis noch ganz anders. Da waren es wirklich 90% Musiker und wirklich nur ganz wenige Normalsterbliche, die sich dafür interessiert haben, was es denn da angeboten wird.
Aber auch Musiker haben ja ein großes Interesse daran, die Sachen von anderen Leuten zu hören.
Das war auch, glaube ich, der Reiz am Anfang, dass eben viele, also eher aus dem Amateurbereich stammende Musiker, eben untereinander sich die Musik angehört haben, vom jeweils anderen. Und das ist natürlich auch für einen Musiker sehr interessant, wenn man eben die Meinung von jemandem hört, der jetzt nicht komplett unbedarft ist, sondern sich selber auch mit der Materie auseinandersetzt. Und dadurch hat sich dann eben auch diese intensive Kommunikation zwischen den Musikern entwickelt.
Die eben dann... Ein Expertenforum sozusagen.
Genau, so das war es gar nicht.
Ja, und eine Statistik darüber, ob die Musiker jetzt mehr bewerten als andere?
Das ist eindeutig so. Also die Musiker bewerten eindeutig mehr als die normalen Musiker.
Das heißt, man kann davon ausgehen, wenn jetzt ein Track weit oben steht, ist eigentlich der Großteil der Leute, die für diese Bewertung gesorgt haben, auch so selber Musiker sind.
Genau, das macht ja die Bewertung eigentlich noch...
Aber es gibt jetzt kein Ranking mit, ich bin Musiker und ich nicht. Und dann zähle ich irgendwie...
Na, das wäre ja schon was wie ein bisschen Faschistoid.
Faktor mehr, ja okay.
Klar, das hatte ich auch schon mal überlegt. Bisher wird das alles wirklich streng demokratisch gehandhabt. Jeder hat eine Stimme quasi. Wenn er sie dann abgibt für einen Musiker, dann zählt das genauso viel, wie wenn eben ein gestandener Musiker, der schon seit zwei Jahren auf der Plattform ist, seine Wertung abgibt. Es war schon mal in der Überlegung, das ein bisschen zu gewichten. Aber davon war bisher jetzt noch nicht unbedingt zwangsläufig die Notwendigkeit, davon Gebrauch zu machen. Darüber hinaus gibt es eben auch so ein bisschen redaktionelle Beiträge, die sich eben auch rund um die Bloggosphäre im Bereich der elektronischen Musik bewegen. Da bin ich dann überwiegend im eigenen Blog, im eigenen Pulsar-Blog, den ich leider auch aufgrund von Personalmangel überwiegend selbst betreue. Also wenn sich einer der höher schreiberischen Fähigkeiten verpflichtet fühlt und diese gerne einbringen möchte, dann kann er sich gerne melden unter Pulsar Records und dann auch gerne selber seinen Senf dazu beitragen. Voraussetzung ist eben, dass man sich thematisch auch um diese Bloggosphäre in dem Bereich bleibt.
Ich glaube, die Bloggerei kommt jetzt langsam erst so rein. Wir haben im Vorfeld der Sendung ja auch schon gesprochen, Musiker und Technik sind eine ganz eigene Geschichte. Insbesondere die Computertechnik, wie man damit umgeht und was man da sozusagen daran schätzt und nicht schätzt. Ich glaube, das ist auch so bei diesen ganzen Kommunikationsformen. Das ist alles erst dabei, sich wirklich zu verquicken. Wir haben es also sehr häufig mit sehr homogenen Netzkulturen zu tun. Die einen benutzen das und die anderen benutzen das. Aber dass man jetzt wirklich mal so ein Medium hat, wie E-Mail, definitiv ist einfach weit verbreitet. Aber schon bei Blogs ist es so eine ganz andere Sache. Dann wird die Diskussion auch breiter.
Genau. Das ist auch ganz wichtig. Das sehe ich auch gerade bei dem Projekt, dass ich eben nicht jetzt wirklich streng nur auf die Musik beschränken will, die da angeboten wird, sondern eben auch so ein bisschen das Drumherum auch mit beleuchten und eben auch nicht nur über die Partys, sondern eben auch über sonstige Veranstaltungen, wie zum Beispiel auch das NetAudio Festival, auf das wir ja noch mal zu sprechen kommen wollen, dass halt einfach auch ein Forum geschaffen werden soll, wo einfach diese ganzen, dieser ganze thematische Komplex sich auch so ein bisschen für den Benutzer erschließt, der eben hinter dieser ganzen NetAudio-Thematik steckt. Das soll eben auch auf jeden Fall mit einfließen bei diesem Projekt.
Das heißt, Pulsar Records bringt nicht eigene Musik raus. Es gibt kein Team, was jetzt wie bei Pentagonik auswählt und dann so ein Release hat, sondern es ist eigentlich ein fortwährendes Releasen auch von einzelnen Tracks.
Genau.
Und also auch diese Idee mit dem Album, diese Klammer aus der klassischen Labelszene ist da schon weg.
Genau, ich fand das einfach konsequenter auch, wenn man dann schon sagt, okay, ich nutze das Netz als Medium. Warum denn dann das eigentlich noch rübernehmen aus der realen Welt oder aus der physikalischen Tonträgerwelt? Warum das denn überhaupt noch ins Netz rüber transportieren, wenn doch eigentlich letztendlich das schon darum geht, ob der einzelne Track jetzt für mich interessant ist oder nicht. Also es gibt auf jeden Fall eine Stilisierung, also man kann eine stilistische Einteilung.
Ja.
Das heißt, man kann schon auswählen, dass man jetzt zum Beispiel Haus oder Tech-House oder Minimal hören möchte oder Ambient oder Drum'n'Bass, aber ansonsten sind wirklich die Tracks alle für sich gleichwertig. Also das ist jetzt nicht so, dass die nochmal gebundelt werden in einer extra Release.
Aber es gibt auch bei Pulsar-Rekord einen Schwerpunkt wahrscheinlich in der elektronischen Musik.
Der ist auf jeden Fall in der elektronischen Musik. Genau. Und es wird auch, also es gibt auch jetzt schon so eine implizite Ansage, dass es eben jetzt nicht so ein Dance, Euro-Dance, Trance oder sowas, dass da halt sowas nicht reingestellt wird, was man ja sowieso überall im Radio hört und so. Also da, die werden auch meistens relativ schnell abgestraft und kehren von alleine dem Pulsar dann relativ schnell auch wieder den Rücken zu. Das heißt, da muss ich auch nicht eingreifen und irgendjemanden rauswerfen, sondern das passiert dann meistens aufgrund der Tatsache, dass eben die Hörerschaft auch so eine gewisse Hörgewohnheit hat. Und alles, was da halt wirklich so komplett gar nicht reinpasst, was entweder zu kommerziell oder eben...
Aber kann es sich denn dann auch ausreichend entwickeln? Also ich meine, wenn jetzt alles gleich rausfliegt, was nicht reinpasst zu dem, was schon da ist, hat dann das Neue da eine Chance?
Ja, ich meine, grundsätzlich ist dieses Projekt natürlich jetzt nicht so ausgelegt, dass es einfach in die Richtung wie MySpace oder so gehen soll, sondern es ist schon implizit auch so gedacht als Plattform für Nischenbeschallung im Bereich der elektronischen Musik. Also es soll jetzt auch kein riesiger Markt erschlossen werden und es sollen jetzt auch keine gigantomanischen Download-Zahlen damit erreicht werden, sondern es soll wirklich eigentlich auch so ein bisschen halt einfach ein Gegenpol zu dem, was uns im Radio und in den sonstigen Medien ebenso um die Ohren geklatscht wird.
Und ein Expertenforum soll es sein.
Das müssen wir halt nicht auch noch bedienen, sondern wir wollen halt dann da schon so ein bisschen unseren Anspruch wahren. Also auch der Gedanke, der am Anfang der Hinterstand war, also beziehungsweise nach dieser Phase, nachdem sich das eben so weiterentwickelt hat, war schon, dass wir eine Plattform sein wollen für anspruchsvolle elektronische Tanzmusik. Und das ist eigentlich auch so. Also unter der Klammer kann man das Ganze betrachten, mehr und nicht weniger. Also alles, was elektronisch ist, was irgendwie so einen gewissen Anspruch an sich selbst stellt, das ist auf jeden Fall willkommen, bei uns eingestellt zu werden. Und dann entscheiden eben die Nutzer, ob das Ganze auch Bestand hat oder ob es dann eher in der Versenkung wieder verschwindet.
Okay, dann hören wir doch mal rein hier in einen dieser Tracks mit besonderem Anspruch.
Ja, der ist ein bisschen schräger, der Song, den wir jetzt hören werden.
Ja, sag mal, was ist dazu?
Das geht so ein bisschen in die Elektro-Richtung.
Ja, die Elektro-Richtung. Kannst du das vielleicht mal erklären? Also mit diesen Genres, das ist ja immer so ein Schuss mit sieben Siegeln.
Klassischer elektronischer Musik. Witzigerweise gibt es ja sogar richtige Beat-Patterns für verschiedene Musikrichtungen. Und das ist erstaunlich, dass zum Beispiel bei Drum & Bass die Kick-Drum und die Snare-Drum, dass die wirklich immer in der gleichen Abfolge im Takt eben erklingen. Und so ist es beim Elektro dann zum Beispiel auch. Also im Prinzip sind das einfach Variationen, eigentlich das Grund rhythmischen Muster, das dem Ganzen zugrunde liegt. Und so kann man eigentlich schon ganz gut eine Unterscheidung machen. Darüber hinaus gibt es dann natürlich ganz viele stilistische Untergattungen, ob jetzt irgendwas eher Tech-House oder eher minimal oder eher progressiver, minimal Techno oder progressive Techno oder Asset-House oder... Also da gibt es dann wirklich in ganz viele verschiedene Richtungen.
Ich sehe Tech-Wolken.
Also zu dem Thema hat irgendwie, glaube ich, so ein Japaner oder so weiter, irgendwie so eine Riesen-Seite, Flash-Seite gemacht.
Ah, die habe ich schon mal gesehen.
Genau.
Ist die gut?
Die ist super. Auf jeden Fall. Vor allem weil er da auf...
Kriegen wir die mal alle noch zusammen, ja? Die sind dann in den Links, okay.
Zumal er irgendwie auch leicht ironisch dann auf Euro-Dance eingeht oder andere Abarten der Musik.
Okay, dann hören wir jetzt erstmal rein, wie der Elektro so klingt. Und vielleicht kannst du mir ja danach erklären, was da jetzt das Typ für...
Genau, Custom Car Commando heißen die. Pictures and Sounds, der Track.
Weißt du auch, wo die herkommen? Die kommen aus China. Die kommen aus China.
Die kommen aus Essen oder so. Also auf...
Auf dem rechten Teil kommt doch alles aus China.
Nein, die meisten. Das stimmt. Vor allem das Spielzeug. Das mit GHB verseuchte Spielzeug.
Okay, also Custom Car Commando. Gucken wir mal, was dabei rauskommt. Ups, da kommt gar nichts raus. Wir können ja alle gleich nochmal anfangen.
Die gute alte 303.
Stimmt, die erkenne sogar ich. Die Geburtsstunde des Technos. Schöneres Assetgequake. Okay, was ist daran jetzt so elektro?
Also, naja, so der Beat auf der 1 und auf der 3, die klappt ganz klar auf der 2 und auf der 4.
Der Experte spricht. Okay, ich höre das nicht aus. Gut, dann ziehen wir mal das Custom-Car-Commando mal wieder in den Hintergrund. Interessanter Punkt, du bist ja auch Musiker. Du bist ja jetzt nicht nur netzbesessen und zu einem Faxkod, und dann bist du ja auch noch Musiker.
Oh Gott.
Und DJ bist du wahrscheinlich auch noch, ne?
Ja, war ich. Das ist dann eine der Sachen, die ich dann wirklich so ein bisschen abgelegt habe.
Das heißt, du hast dir die Frau fürs Leben schon gefunden. Da brauch ich auch keinen DJ mehr zu sein.
Du machst Live-Acts.
Genau, das auch noch. Mach mich fertig. Okay, damit hast du natürlich noch einen etwas anderen Zugang. Das hört man ja auch schon raus. Was ist denn so der Musiker-Bedarf, der dann durch Netlabels oder durch diese Net-Music-Szene gedeckt wird? Was war denn vorher falsch, was jetzt besser wird?
Zunächst mal, was natürlich der absolute Mega-Bonus der Net-Label-Szene ist, ist, dass alles so schön per Mausklick verfügbar ist. Was aus der Zeit, als ich selber noch Platten gekauft und auch mal irgendwo gespielt habe, es ist mir halt auch noch sehr gut bekannt, wie viel Zeit man in den Plattenläden verbringt und wie oft man dann irgendwie, nachdem man sich 50, 60 Platten angehört hat, dann irgendwie vielleicht mal fünf oder sechs mit nach Hause genommen hat. Und von denen fünf oder sechs waren dann zwei gut und die anderen, die hat man dann einfach mehr oder weniger, weil man schon gar nicht mehr richtig gehört hat, dann einfach so mitgenommen. Also es hat einfach den Vorteil, dass man so als Konsument optimal bedient wird, weil ich kann mir alles kostenlos runterladen und kann das im Zweifelsfall, wenn ich dann doch morgen feststelle, oh, das war doch nicht so gut, was hat mich denn da geritten, diesen Track runterzuladen, dann hat das halt einfach nicht viel Kosten und Schmerzen verursacht. Ich habe zwar einen Mausklick umsonst getätigt, aber den Platz auf meiner Festplatte kann ich ganz einfach auch wieder freigeben, was ja bei so einer schönen Shellac nicht der Fall ist. Die habe ich dann bei mir zu Hause und kann sie dann irgendwann mal wieder verkaufen für ein Zehntel des Preises und habe dann eben eigentlich ein bisschen Geld und Zeit eigentlich beim Fenster rausgeworfen. Wobei das gleiche Problem hat man natürlich bis zum gewissen Grad auch, dass im Plattenladen einfach auch man erschlagen wird von dem Angebot, das hat man natürlich im Netlabel-Bereich auch, aber da hatten wir ja vorhin auch schon mal das Thema da, ist dann wiederum das Label auch ganz gut und da erfüllt dann auch das Netlabel seinen Zweck, dass man einfach schon mal so eine gewisse Vorauswahl hat, die dann für Qualität birgt oder zumindest für so eine gewisse Stoßrichtung, die ich eben wieder finden möchte bei dem, wonach ich gerade suche.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt als DJ, du bist kein DJ mehr, oder wirst es vielleicht irgendwann mal wieder sein, man braucht ja eigentlich einen permanenten Zulauf von frischem Zeug.
Genau.
Man braucht immer wieder mehr von dem Stoff.
Genau. Und wenn man eben nicht die Zeit und nicht das Geld hat, sich diesen frischen Stoff im Plattenladen zu besorgen, dann liegt eigentlich nichts näher, als sich die Musik dann einfach aus dem Netz zu holen. Mittlerweile geht das eben auch schon ganz gut.
Und ist das dann eine qualitative Einschränkung? Also ist es so, dass so die funkelnden Diamanten, die liegen dann alle auf Vinyl rum? So und das, was keiner haben will, das gibt es dann im Netz?
Lange Zeit war das so. Mittlerweile muss ich aber sagen, dass sich da schon einfach auch diverse Netlabel mittlerweile auch hervortun durch erstklassige Releases, die man auf jeden Fall auch durchaus im Club spielen kann, wo dann eben nicht die Tanzfläche sofort leer ist. Und auch die Qualität der Produktion hat eben stark angezogen, auch in den letzten anderthalb Jahren, würde ich mal sagen. Also am Anfang war es echt so, dass man manchmal sogar richtig geile Stücke auch gefunden hat im Netz, die dann aber einfach nicht den nötigen Druck entfaltet haben, um dann eben im Club auch…
Ja, also so rein von der Audio-Technik sozusagen.
Genau, das ist ja auch klar. Ich meine, man hat einfach nicht so hohe Eintrittsbarrieren und wenn jemand ein Label hat und irgendwas auf Vinyl presst, dann wird er natürlich schon vorher auch dafür sorgen, dass das Ganze entsprechend komprimiert ist. Davon abgesehen, dass sich eine Vinyl auch wirklich scheiße anhört, wenn man sie eben nicht vorher auch für Vinyl mastert. Das Audiomaterial wird speziell für die Produktion auf Vinyl vorbereitet, damit das am Ende eben auch druckvoll klingt. Diesen Nachteil hatte eben die Net-Audio-Szene, dass das eben nicht unbedingt erforderlich war. Also man konnte ja den Track auch in absolut unkomprimierter und leise oder mit irgendwelchen Click-Artefakten oder was womöglich noch im Hintergrund, konnte man ja trotzdem online stellen. Da gibt es jetzt erstmal keine Barriere wie beim herkömmlichen Label, das einfach ein Teufel tun wird und so viel Geld für eine Plattenpressung ausgeben, wenn da irgendwie das Material nicht hundertprozentig in Ordnung ist. Da gab es am Anfang auf jeden Fall ein Qualitätsproblem, das aber mittlerweile immer mehr in den Hintergrund tritt. Zumindest bei den Netlabeln, die sich so ein bisschen etabliert haben und die eben…
Woran liegt das?
Das ist einfach erschwinglicher geworden, man stellt im Jahres- oder Monatsrhythmus kommt neue Software und neue Hardware auf den Markt, das heißt es wird immer einfacher auch für jemanden zu Hause mit minimalstem Budget absolut erstklassige Ergebnisse zu erzielen. Also wenn ich überlege, zum Beispiel was ich zu Hause an, selbst mit meinem minimalsten Equipment, wenn ich damit auf Tour gehe, irgendwo spielen gehe, dann habe ich da einfach einen Umfang an Möglichkeiten, die vor zehn Jahren alleine noch wahrscheinlich mit einem Budget von 20.000 Euro noch nicht erschwinglich gewesen wären.
Und jetzt hast du 1.000 Euro investiert, oder?
Genau, ein bisschen mehr ist es dann schon, aber man kann auf jeden Fall, also in den letzten zehn Jahren hat sich auch auf jeden Fall die Anschaffung um ein Zehntel reduziert, um das gleiche. Und vor 20 Jahren war es wahrscheinlich der Faktor 100.
Und das heißt, man kann jetzt, also der Fluss der Musik wird schneller, die Produktionsqualität gleicht sich an, kann man sagen. Führt das dann auch dazu, dass da neue, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das angehen soll, aber dieses große Rätsel bei den Netlabels. Also das Rätsel, was jetzt, sagen wir mal, bei den Hörern jetzt gerade, bei mir so und aber auch in der breiten Diskussion, in der Öffentlichkeit immer wieder da ist, ist immer so, okay, was treibt die ganze Sache und ist das, steht das jetzt in Konkurrenz zu dem Etablierten? Ist das was vollkommen Paralleles, was einfach etwas tut, was vorher noch nie da war oder ist das jetzt the next big thing, was alles andere später aufsaugt? Ist das so Musikindustrie 2.0?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob wir das in Deutschland vielleicht ein bisschen anders sehen oder so. Ich hatte mich neulich auf dem NetAutoFest mit dem Netlabel TonyMusic unterhalten, das irgendwie wirklich auf hohem Niveau produziert, produzieren die halt Releases, Veröffentlichungen und die haben da wie eine ganz andere Herangehensweise. Die bringen zum Teil sowieso schon auf Platte ihre Releases raus und im Prinzip auch einige Releases, die auch online rauskommen, die auf demselben Niveau sind. Und die haben dann schon lange nicht mehr so eine klare Trennung für mich. Da ist es im Prinzip egal, ob es dann jetzt irgendwie auf Platte rauskommt oder ob es online rauskommt. Natürlich gibt es dann immer noch einen kleinen Unterschied, aber die haben halt einfach einen super guten Anspruch an guter Musik, dass es so gegeben sein sollte. Ich glaube, es wird sich immer mehr verschmelzen, gerade weil das vielleicht noch ein Aspekt wäre, den man vorhin erwähnen könnte, dass gerade auch immer mehr Netlabels in Erscheinung treten und dass man dann automatisch eine Filterfunktion aufbaut, indem man ein gutes Netlabel ist. Es gibt ja auch diverse Plattformen.
Das gibt es auch schon. Also es gibt Netlabels mit Reputation.
Ja, würde ich sagen.
Das gehört dann auch dazu.
Das müssen andere entscheiden. Ich bin auch nicht ganz gut. Und den Chaos-Compilation-Congress find ich auch ganz toll. Also, nee, das ist halt einfach so dann, es ist auch ein bisschen so eine Awareness, also oder beziehungsweise der Anspruch an Musik sozusagen ist in der Szene halt auch oft so, irgendwie haust du halt andauernd Releases raus, irgendwie so oder kümmerst du dich um die Künstler, das ist es. Das ist so ein Sammelsurium von Eindrücken, das kommt halt auch bei vielen Leuten an.
Ich glaube, diese Dynamik aus der Netlabel-Szene, die hat so ein bisschen auch Vorbildcharakter für die klassischen Labels. Weil so ein bisschen sieht man das schon, dass sich das so ein bisschen angleicht. Das ist halt einfach eine neue Entwicklung, die die großen Majors einfach nicht so nachvollzogen haben. Wie es ja oft so ist, sind dann eher so die kleinen innovativen Leutchen, die ohne großes Team da einfach rangehen und dann einfach irgendwas Neues anstoßen, was dann eben so eine Eigendynamik entwickelt. Und ich glaube, wir sind gerade eben an dem Punkt, wo diese Szene so ein bisschen auf der Schwelle dahin geht, dass sie eben erwachsen wird. Und das wird auch mit Sicherheit so die Bereiche, die für die herkömmlichen Musikvertriebswege attraktiv sind, die werden mit Sicherheit dann auch von den Majors so ein bisschen kopiert werden. Das sieht man ja jetzt auch schon. Also, weiß ich nicht, Radio hat das nur bedingt ein gutes Beispiel, weil die Sache dann doch irgendwie nur so halb...
Dieses Release ihres letzten Albums, wo dann jeder selber sagen kann, wie viel er dafür bezahlen will.
Genau, es gibt aber schon auch andere Labels. Also Unfound Sound und Found Sound ist zum Beispiel so ein gutes Beispiel für wirklich ein Plattenlabel, was sowohl eine online als auch eine Vinyl- und CD-Sparte hat, wo man eben einerseits die Sachen... Also ein gewisses...
Es gibt gleich zwei Ausprägerungen, Found und Unfound?
Genau, es gibt... Also es sind aber nicht die gleichen Releases.
Als Unfound Sound kannte ich sie, aber egal.
Genau, es gibt eben auch Found Sound und da gibt es dann wirklich die herkömmlichen Tonträger zum Anfassen. Und ich denke mal, das wird auch in Zukunft weiter so laufen. Es ist z.B. denkbar, dass gewisse große Medien......
dass sich Netlabels noch sozusagen mit ranklatschen.
Die halten sich dann noch so ein kleines Netlabel, um nochmal auch in der Net-Audioszene und überhaupt im Netz eben präsent zu sein und auch einfach einen Promotionwirkung auch durch das kostenfreie Bereitstellen von Musik zu erreichen. Auf der anderen Seite werden sie natürlich nicht auf die bisherigen Vertriebskanäle verzichten, weil dadurch natürlich einfach auch die Kosten dann gedeckt werden müssen.
Ja, das ist das Modell, was Geld erzeugt, das ist ja auch für die Musiker ein Thema.
Genau, ich bin auch dagegen, das so allzu dogmatisch zu betrachten, dieses Thema, weil einerseits ist es natürlich schon schön für den Konsumenten, wenn er sich die Musik kostenlos runterladen kann. Auf der anderen Seite muss man natürlich auch sehen, dass irgendjemand diese Musik auch erstellt hat und eben ja am liebsten vielleicht davon leben möchte, zumindest aber vielleicht irgendwann mal in die Lage kommen will, dass er auch wenn das Equipment jetzt so schön billig ist, wie wir schon gesagt haben, gewisse Kosten verursacht es eben doch. Und ich bin persönlich auch der Meinung, dass es schon in Zukunft wünschenswert wäre, wenn das auch funktioniert, dass die Labels einfach in die Lage versetzt sehen, sich auch ein bisschen monetär einfach zu tragen. Ich glaube, momentan ist es halt so, dass aufgrund der mangelnden Akzeptanz von bezahlten Dienstleistungen im Netz, dass einfach nicht möglich ist, solche Sachen dann gegen kleines Geld anzubieten. Ich denke mal, in Zukunft hängt vielleicht auch damit zusammen, dass es keine wirklich funktionierenden Micro-Payment-Abrechnungssysteme gibt. Aber ich könnte mir eben auch vorstellen, dass hochqualitative Netlabel dann dazu übergehen, ihre Releases für kleines Geld, sagen wir mal 20, 30 Cent pro Track oder so anzubieten. Und ich persönlich würde darin auch keine moralische Verfehlung sehen, weil irgendwie ist es ja doch eine Leistung, die man gibt als Label. Und man hat ja auch so ein bisschen den Musikern, die im eigenen Pool schwimmen, auch die Verpflichtung gegenüber, dass man denen halt auch die bestmögliche Promo nach außen liefert. Und um das machen zu können, braucht man eben einfach leider in unserer heutigen Welt ein bisschen Kohle. Kohle?
Ja, also ich bin mir da nicht so sicher. Also ich denke, dass das gar nicht mal so ist, dass die Leute jetzt im Netz generell Dienstleistungen gering schätzen. Ich glaube einfach nur, dass die Dienstleistungen bisher einfach noch nicht gepasst haben. Dass viele Leute geglaubt haben, dass sie jetzt mit dieser und jener Dienstleistung, die biete ich jetzt mal an, dann hat keiner gleich laut losgeschrien und seine Geldbörse gezückt. Und daraus kam dann so schnell diese Ableitung, das funktioniert ja eh nicht im Internet, die wollen ja alles nur kostenlos haben. iTunes ist ja vielleicht das beste Beispiel, die ja auch gezeigt haben, dass man einfach auch einen ganz normalen Musikvertrieb machen kann. Die haben sich natürlich dann gleich an die Major's...
Das ist natürlich ein großer Konzern, der das auch sich leisten kann, so was ins Leben zu rufen und dann natürlich auch mit den entsprechenden Werben...
Klar, aber wird das angenommen, ob das ein großer oder ein kleiner Konzern, das ist ja den Leuten vollkommen egal. Interessant ist ja nur, ist die Dienstleistung das Geld wert? Und wenn ja, dann lege ich da halt meinen Dollar auf den Tisch. Und das tun sie ja offensichtlich vielleicht nicht in überbordend großen Zahlen, aber zumindest größer als alles das, was vorher da war. Und warum sollte das jetzt nicht auch für andere Musik gelten? Also ich frage mich vor allem, warum ist diese ganze Net-Audioszene hier nicht auch noch bei iTunes erblätterbar?
Also da gibt es eigentlich einen ganz erklärbaren Grund. Also der ganze Musikmarkt ist extrem groß. Der elektronische Musikmarkt ist ein Teil davon, ein sehr kleiner Teil davon. Und ich würde sagen, der Teil der Netlabels ist dann noch ein kleinerer Teil davon. Also die Zielgruppe selber existiert noch nicht, vielleicht oder beziehungsweise gibt es so nicht, dass da vielleicht enorm viel Geld hinter stecken würde. Das wissen auch die meisten Netlabel-Betreiber. Aber was Timor halt gerade meint, ist, es wäre wunderbar, wenn ich unseren Künstlern einfach auch ein bisschen Geld geben könnte, damit sie mal die Zeit hätten, einen guten Track zu produzieren und damit auch zufrieden sind. So ist es dann immer so nach Feierabendproduktion, wo wir auch immer versuchen, natürlich, oder am Wochenende, wie auch immer, wenn man Zeit hat, einen Standard aufrechtzuerhalten, genauso wie wir das Netlabel nebenbei betreiben oder so. Aber es wäre natürlich schön, wenn man dann da auch Geld bekommen würde für...
Das heißt, die Leute, die jetzt bei euch die Musik rausbringen, die würden diese Musik sowieso machen? Oder machen die jetzt nur Musik, weil ihr sie treibt? Oder fühlen die sich dadurch ermutigt, das überhaupt erst zu machen, weil es so ein Outlet gibt?
Bedingt sich, ja.
Ich glaube eigentlich, die würden das auf jeden Fall auch so machen. Letztendlich die Netlabel, die schöpfen natürlich auch aus dem Angebot, dass die breite Schar an Musikern bereitstellt. Es gibt einfach so viele Musiker, eben auch dadurch bedingt, dass es heutzutage auch nicht mehr so teuer ist, sich sein eigenes kleines Homestudio einzurichten, dass einfach auch extrem viel Material vorhanden ist. Und ich glaube, aus diesem Überangebot an mehr oder weniger gut produzierter Musik ist immer auch diese Netlabel-Szene entstanden. Und jetzt ist eben eigentlich so ein bisschen der Scheitelpunkt erreicht, wo man sich dann entweder fragt, ob man das Ganze dann in Zukunft auch mit professionellen Anspruch weitermacht. Dann sieht man sich leider auch monetären Gesetzmäßigkeiten unterworfen, wie sie einfach herrschen in unserer Gesellschaft. Oder ob man das eben weiterhin als Just-for-fun-Projekt betreibt und dann hat man halt einfach auch diese Zwänge nicht, die man sich dann da unterwerfen muss. Und ich glaube, genauso wird sich das auch aufteilen. Es wird weiterhin in Zukunft Netlabels geben, die eben einfach das kostenfreie Anbieten von Musik als höchste Maxime ansehen. Dann wird es wiederum auch andere geben, die das Ganze eben so in einen semikommerziellen Rahmen bringen werden, um ihre Musiker zu bezahlen oder halt einfach auch eigene Betriebskosten, die man ja als Label auch hat. Auch ein Netlabel muss ja zum Beispiel Serverkosten bezahlen. Ich kann jetzt nur die Zahlen vom Pulsaren heranziehen, aber es sind halt auf jeden Fall schon dreistellige Summen, die eigentlich im Monat reinkommen müssten, um dieses Projekt zu finanzieren. Das ist jetzt natürlich auf lange Sicht schon irgendwie die Frage, ob das für einen Labelbetreiber so interessant ist, ein Projekt wirklich aus der eigenen Tasche zu finanzieren.
Ja, es ist nicht wenig Geld, es ist jedes Jahr ein großer neuer Computer, den man sich stattdessen auch kaufen könnte.
Genau, und da muss man halt schon sehen, dass man auch so ein bisschen an die Hörer dann irgendwann mal, wenn sich die Szene dann noch weiter ausgebreitet hat, eben dann schon auch vielleicht so ein bisschen appellieren kann, dass sie einfach eine gewisse Wertschätzung auch dem entgegenbringen, dass man ihnen einfach die Musik kostenfrei, frei Haus nach Hause liefert.
Ich habe den Eindruck, so ein Net-Audio, das ist so das Blogging der Musik. Also während die Journalisten ihre teuren Artikel da in der Zeit abdrucken oder im Spiegel voll bezahlt werden, dann gibt es da so die Blogger, die schreiben sich die Finger wund und kriegen keinen Cent, aber können es auch nicht sein lassen. Und so ist es ein bisschen mit Net-Audio auch.
So ist es auch, wir können es einfach nicht lassen.
Ja, das ist ganz gut so. Ach Gott, es gibt noch so viele Themen, auf denen ich kommen wollte. Also ganz so pessimistisch darf man es wirklich nicht sehen.
Was war denn daran pessimistisch? Dass der Abschaum in der Blogosphäre...
Ich würde ja niemals sagen, dass die Blogosphäre das wäre, nicht der Abschaum.
Aber zum Gegenteil, das ist das, wo sich die Zukunft bewegt.
Das ist der Leerboden, könnte man auch sagen.
Gar keine Frage, ich sehe das sehr positiv. Es ist ja immer schwierig, die Motivation nachzuvollziehen von anderen Leuten. Man fragt sich ja immer, warum machen die das eigentlich? Beim Bloggen kann ich es irgendwie verstehen, weil da habe ich auch selber so ein bisschen meine Hände mit auf der Tastatur. Also bei Musik, gerade wenn ich mich ja... Wir starren hier die ganze Zeit hier auf den Monitor, wo so die Audio-Software... Ich verwende ja hier fürs Podcasting im Prinzip...
Eine wunderbare Name....
Ja, kann man gerne sagen.
Wie heißt die Firma noch gleich?
Ableton Live. Das haben sie mir auch einfach so zur Verfügung gestellt, weil sie wissen, dass ich eh kein Markt bin. Ja, da kann man sich auch gerne mal für bei bedanken. Andererseits haben die für Podcasts da kein Ohr. Ja, das ist für die genauso wenig Zielgruppe, wie jetzt bei euch da auch Mikrozielgruppen für die Musikindustrie uninteressant sind. Da haben wir das gleiche Leid, aber das ist halt einfach auch an der Stelle Experimentierfeld. Jetzt hast du ja vorhin gesagt... Also ich wollte jetzt mal diese Querfinanzierungsgeschichte kommen. Jetzt haben wir irgendwie die 300 Euro da im Monat, die dann irgendwo wegbezahlt werden. Ihr macht ja auch Partys. Von Pentagonik her. Und ihr beide wart jetzt auch, glaube ich, im Boot bei der Gründung dieser Netlag-Partys. Könntest du uns sagen, was dahinter stand und wann das losging?
Im Januar 2006 haben wir uns zusammengefunden. Wir kannten uns auch schon vorher, aber dann haben wir eben einfach auch so ein bisschen der Notwendigkeit den Tribut gezollt, dass man einfach auch der Öffentlichkeit so ein bisschen dieses Phänomen präsentiert. Mittlerweile ist es ja so, dass die Medien das auch schon so ein bisschen aufgegriffen haben, die Net-Audio-Szene und die Netlabel-Szene. Zu der Zeit, als wir angefangen haben, nämlich im Januar 2006, war das Ganze noch nicht der Fall. Da war eben außerhalb von den, ja, von den hartgesottenen Net-Audio-Jüngern, die eben irgendwie schon auch Kontakt dazu hatten und meistens eben auch aus der Musiker- oder zumindest aus der sehr Internet-affinen Szene stammten, dass wir eben wollten, dass dieses Phänomen Net-Audio und die Netlabel-Szene, dass das einfach in einer größeren Öffentlichkeit vorgestellt wird. Und das erreicht man eben am besten, indem man die Musik da hinbringt, wo sie eben auch gehört wird und am besten auch noch dazu getanzt wird, nämlich im Club. Da haben wir uns dann mit Raimund Reintjes vom RAW in Berlin-Friedrichshain zusammengetan. Also, RAW ist dieses reißbare Ausbesserungswerk, so eine dieser, in der Riveala-Straße. Sehr geile Location, das ist ein wunderbares Gelände.
Genau, in Friedrichshain.
Da haben wir eben dann auch in Raimund ein wirklich sehr...
Also, in Friedrichshain muss man ja sagen, wir haben auch unsere Zuhörer weltweit.
Auf jeden Fall sind wir dann bei Raimund auf sehr offene Ohren gestoßen. Der war eben selber auch einer der wenigen, die auch schon ein bisschen mit der Netlabels-Szene in Kontakt gekommen waren davor. Er kommt eigentlich eher so ein bisschen aus der Dub-Szene. Wir haben eben eine Location gesucht, Don und ich, und sind dann auf Raimund gestoßen und haben im RAW dann eigentlich so den optimalen Rahmen gefunden, um für uns dann da eine Veranstaltungsreihe aufzuziehen. Die haben wir dann gemacht und es lief auch sehr erfolgreich.
Wie häufig lief das jetzt? Ich glaube so vier, fünf?
14, 15 Partys waren das.
Echt, so viel habe ich schon verpasst. Ich war auf der ersten. Ich war auf der ersten.
Genau, und das, ja, also wir wollen uns jetzt auch nicht allzu sehr selber auf die Schulter klopfen, aber so ein bisschen ist es schon so, dass eben durch die Netlag einfach dieses Phänomen dann wirklich auch eine breitere Öffentlichkeit dann auch gefunden haben. Und insofern unser originärer Gedanke da auch seine Entsprechung gefunden hat in der Realität. Also das ist dann schon echt hoch. Das denke ich auch.
Das ist jetzt mein Telefon. Ich habe eine tolle Nachricht erhalten.
Lies sie doch mal vor.
Hier beschwert sich gerade einer über die Lautstärke eines letzten Chaosradio Express. Das stimmt auch. Aber das habe ich mittlerweile verbessert, weil ich euch ja ja gerade vorher schon gezeigt habe.
Aber das ist doch wunderbar, dass du jetzt sozusagen das Feedback eines Hörers auch noch...
Genau. Wenn ich nur wüsste, wer es ist. Ich glaube, die Telefonnummer ist mir vollkommen irgendwie...
Das ist auch so ein Phänomen, dass man sich keine Telefonnummern mehr merken kann. Seitdem diese Handy... Aber gut, dass wir wahrscheinlich auch noch mal...
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das jemals wollte. Okay, also diese Netlag-Partys haben stattgefunden, finden auch weiterhin noch statt, oder?
Ja, wir haben jetzt eine kleine Pause gemacht, weil wir eben insbesondere durch das NetAudio-Festival natürlich erheblich eingespannt waren.
Genau, darauf wollte ich jetzt nämlich eigentlich auch hinauskommen.
Aber um das noch mal kurz zu sagen, wir sind momentan eben wieder auf der Suche nach einer neuen Location, weil wir dann jetzt gesagt haben, okay, zwei Jahre RAV-Tempel ist dann auch genug.
Weil es sich dann wahrscheinlich auch zu sehr mit der Location verklebt.
Genau, also wir haben auch so schon mal kleine Gastspiele in anderen Locations gehabt, aber momentan...
Aber immer in Berlin?
Immer in Berlin, ja, bisher. War auch sogar schon mal die Überlegung, das Ganze auch mal in andere Städte zu transportieren, wird vielleicht sogar auch kommen. Jetzt, momentan, ist aber erst mal so die neue, also sozusagen nochmal so ein Kick-Off zu machen und das Ganze dann auch in die nächste Etappe zu führen. Und so wahrscheinlich voraussichtlich im Februar 2008 wird dann die nächste Netlag stattfinden.
Oh, das ist dann noch eine Weile hin.
Das ist noch ein bisschen hin, ja.
Ah, da fällt mir wieder ein, dass ich immer das Datum sagen wollte. Schon wieder vergessen.
Das heutige Datum?
Ja, damit man... Weißt du, wie das ist? Diese Audio-Wellen, die werden jetzt ins Weltall geschickt, die spiegeln sich dann von verschiedenen Planeten und kommen dann irgendwann bei extraterrestrischen Anderen. Die sollen ja auch wissen, wann es ist. Also, den 12. November 2007 haben wir... Ich nehme hier schon die nächste Sendung auf, wo ich die letzte noch nicht mal gepostet habe. Ja, dieses Net-Audio-Festival, das hattet ihr vor kurzem organisiert. In Berlin, auch da im RRW. Was war das? Das war eine Konferenz und da habt ihr die ganzen Netlabels zusammengebracht?
Oder eine Zusammenkunft aller Netlabels?
Aller Netlabels, kann man nicht sagen. Das hatten wir ja nie als 1.000 gehabt, aber schon eine ganze Menge.
Der größten Netlabels. Ich hätte mir vorstellen können, wie viele Netlabels da so vertreten waren. Es waren über 25 Netlabels und 55 Artists. Es war auch dasselbe Team wie Netlag, ergänzt durch einige andere Mitarbeiter. Es war im Prinzip eine Weiterführung des Netlag-Konzepts. Es gab ja auch eine Party dabei. Genau, das war auch ein zentrales Element. Was auch sehr wichtig war, war das Tagesprogramm. Da hatten wir diverse Vorträge und Workshops, die zum Teil auch kostenlos waren.
Wo man auch gesehen hat, dass über dieses Partygehen hinaus mittlerweile ein Interesse darin besteht, sich der Leute in dem Themenbereich weiterzubilden und zu informieren. Wir waren positiv über die Resonanz dieser tagsüber stattfindenden Veranstaltung überrascht. Da gab es Workshops, Diskussionsrunden und Vorträge. Es gab auch eine Abschlussdiskussionsrunde, wo über 100 Leute waren. Das hört sich jetzt gar nicht so viel an, aber ich glaube, ich habe dich auch gesehen.
Ja, da habe ich es dann auch noch geschafft. Ich hatte recht wenig Zeit und habe es kurzfristig erst mitbekommen, aber das wollte ich mir schon noch anschauen.
Genau, das wurde auch wirklich gut angenommen.
Wir haben viel Feedback bekommen, gerade was die Workshops betrifft. Wir haben Ableton-Workshops und Native-Workshops gemacht.
Genau, das waren auch unsere beiden Sponsoren. Wir hatten also auch ein bisschen Unterstützung.
Und die Vorträge waren zum Teil sehr komprimiert, weil wir eine große Anzahl von Vorträgen hatten, aber das war eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht. Dadurch konnte irgendwie jeder den Vortragsstrang mitbekommen. Und ja, wir waren echt froh. Im Nachhinein war man natürlich auch froh, dass das vorbei war. Die Organisation war echt enorm.
Du kennst das ja.
Also es war wirklich ein Kraftakt. Man kann auch dazu sagen, alle drei, die wir als Kernteam mitbetreut haben, haben wir danach erstmal alle eine Woche krank. Und wir lagen richtig flach.
Ich schleppse jetzt immer noch mit mir mit. Das war auf jeden Fall wichtig, vor allem, weil viele Netlabels sich getroffen haben. Da gab es zum Beispiel diese eine witzige Anekdote von diesem... vom Aldiology war es, glaube ich. Nein, Tonatom, Tonatom war ein Netlabel. Und der hatte reigen Kontakt zu seinem Fotografen.
Und die haben sich erstmals wirklich auf dem Net Audio Festival getroffen, obwohl sie schon seit zwei oder seit wie langer Zeit zusammenarbeiten?
Also er hat nicht fünf Jahre nur per E-Mail Kontakt gehabt, sondern einmal per Telefon. Und dann hatten sie sich dann zum ersten Mal getroffen. Das war echt wirklich romantisch.
Wie romantisch? Da können wir mal ein bisschen romantische Musik einspielen. Wir haben hier Musik versprochen und es kommen keine.
Tanz in den Morgen ist doch...
Das sorge ich auch dafür, dass der Regler gleich aufgedreht ist. Den Tanz in den Morgen...
Ja, der ist sehr romantisch. Der ist so romantisch.
Von Einklang, das ist jetzt aus Pulsar herausgefallen.
So am Rande bemerkt, Einklang ist eines der Gründungsmitglieder, kann man nicht ganz sagen. Sie kamen etwas später mit dazu, aber bereits Anfang 2004, als die Plattform ins Leben gerufen wurde, war sie eben eine von diesen Musikern, die gleich so ziemlich von Anfang an mitgemischt haben. Und das ist auch ein ziemlich alter Track, der auch schon relativ lange auf dem Pulsar rumliegt.
Und der ist noch nicht rausgefallen, oder was, aus der Bewertung?
Nö, der ist noch nicht rausgefallen.
Geht das überhaupt?
Nee, wenn der einmal aufgenommen ist, dann bleibt der da auch. Dann bleibt der auch drin. Ich glaube, der hat die Track-ID Nummer 67 oder so. Also da sieht man schon, das ist wirklich ein ganz früher Track. Mittlerweile sind die ja schon bei den 3000, weiß nicht, 3000 oder 4000.
Okay, gut, dann hören wir mal rein in die Nummer 67.
Mir! Also es wird auch gesungen, ja. Also elektronische Musik hat ja jetzt eigentlich immer so ein bisschen den Nimbus, dass es eigentlich nur Klum-Bum und Bum-Bum ist.
Aber dem ist nicht so.
Ne, neben Bum-Bum haben wir auch Sänger ab. Ihr habt auch Sänger?
Jaja, also wir haben einen Sänger, der ist auch mal regelmäßig dabei.
Moderner Heinos.
Jaja, das müssen wieder andere entscheiden. Wie Heino klingt.
Ne, nicht, dass die so klingen wie er. Aber so erfolgreich sind vielleicht wie Heino.
Ja, Marco. Er hat Samples eingespielt.
Es wird immer viel remixed.
Wir hatten bei der ersten Netlag eine sehr gute Sängerin mit einem Jazz-Gitaristen. Ich weiß nicht, erste oder zweite war es.
Sie war aber auch mal hip bei uns. Und die hat auch eine sehr geile Performance auf der Bühne abgeliefert. Also Einklang war auch mal auf einer Netlag und hat auch wirklich mit Schlagzeuger und mit ihrer Stimme live performt. Also elektronische Musik heißt eben nicht nur, dass da eventuell sich auch mal ein Vocal-Schnipsel verirrt. Sondern das kann auch durchaus heißen, dass eben jemand auf der Bühne steht und da live was dazu singt. Und das ist eben trotzdem elektronische Musik, weil eben da dann gleichzeitig auch noch eine ganze Menge Sound aus dem Rechner kommt.
Oder diese speziellen Beatmuster dann wieder.
Dittiridoo-Spiele hatten wir auch noch schon mal.
Wir waren ja eben beim Netaudio-Festival, dass die ganzen Netlabels da zusammengekommen sind. Waren die sich irgendwie alle einig?
Ja, nee, also ich meine, es wäre ja auch schlimm, wenn das dann so eine homogene Masse ergeben würde, dann bräuchte man ja eigentlich nur noch ein Netlabel, das dann alles abdeckt. Also es war auch schon, also ich meine, es gab sicherlich auch zwischendurch mal so ein bisschen Desens. Also im Nachhinein wurde da zum Beispiel so ein bisschen auch angelastet, dass eben der elektronische Anteil einfach so hoch war und eben auch zum Beispiel, dass der Fokus auf Tech House und Minimal eben vermeintlich zu stark gesetzt worden sei von uns jetzt. Da müssen wir einfach, ja, das so ein bisschen zurückweisen, weil das eben einfach so ist, dass tatsächlich die Net-Audio-Szene sich im überwiegenden Anteil eben aus genau diesen Musikrichtungen rekrutiert und wir natürlich dann auch nochmal so ein bisschen ein Augenmerk drauf haben müssen, ob das Ganze eben auch tanzbar ist.
Ich glaube, du hast dein Mikrofon ein bisschen zu nah am Kinn, das wummert ein bisschen, genau. Das hab ich nicht rausgebracht, ne? Ja, okay, aber warum denn eigentlich nur diese beiden? Also ich meine, auch in elektronischer Musik gibt's ja viel Genres.
Nee, das wurde auf jeden Fall auch mit abgebildet. Aber der Fokus, der war dann eben einfach aufgrund der vielen Anfragen, die wir bekommen haben, die eben genau aus diesem Bereich kommen.
Ist auch ein Berliner Ding, oder?
Ja, genau. Also ich meine, es wäre auch nicht unbedingt sinnvoll, das dann nicht auch abzubilden. Also wenn es nun mal so ist, dass dieser Fokus so stark darauf liegt, dann ist es ja auch Aufgabe eines Net-Audio-Festivals, genau die Szene auch so ein bisschen so abzubilden, wie sie nun mal einfach ist. Und wenn der Anteil an Tech House und Minimal und dergleichen eben so hoch ist, dann wird sich das mit Sicherheit auch in einem Festival widerspiegeln, das eben genau aus diesen Bereichen sich rekrutiert. Aber trotzdem hatten wir da auch eine schöne Vielfalt, auch an Musikern, die eben auch mit Gitarre auf der Bühne standen oder sonstige...
Und für die es dann auch das passende Label gibt?
Für die gibt es dann auch das passende Label, ja. Wie gesagt, hoffentlich in Zukunft noch mehr.
Gibt es denn überhaupt ein Label, was sich jetzt auch mal außerhalb dieses populären Bereichs der elektronischen Musik bewegt?
Ja, ja, da gibt es ganz viele. Also Intoxic zum Beispiel fällt mir da jetzt gerade ein. Ideology ist ein relativ großer namhafter Vertreter, auch eines der größeren Netlabels, die eben auch...
Und was machen die dann? Also was ist so deren Ding?
Na ja, da gibt es dann wirklich auch über Dub oder eben auch wirklich richtig analoge, ehrliche Musik auch. Nicht dieser verlogene digitale Scheiß.
Also ein Kommentar war, glaube ich, von dem einen meinte, er meinte, er würde sich ganz gerne mal einen Jazz-Netlabel wünschen. Ja, super. Jetzt stellt man sich dann wirklich die Frage, warum ist das so? Warum gibt es kein Jazz-Netlabel?
Vielleicht weil die Jazzmusiker alle noch kein Internetzugang haben?
Genau, ich denke, es liegt wahrscheinlich wirklich auch bis zum Gewissen gerade einfach an dieser fehlenden Internetaffinität, die einfach in der elektronischen Musikszene naturgegeben ist, einfach viel höher ist als bei allen, die eher analog oder im Probenraum oder sonst irgendwo rumschrabbeln. Ich komme selber auch aus der Ecke. Ich habe mich auch mit Leuten früher getroffen und habe in irgendein Moabita Keller mit Schlagzeug, mit Keyboard, Gitarre, Bass und Sänger auch Musik gemacht. Also ich persönlich würde mir auf jeden Fall wünschen, dass das auch viel mehr noch Einzug hält in die Netlabels-Szene. Und das wird, glaube ich, auch so kommen. Mit etwas Verzögerung. Die elektronische Musikerzunft hat da so ein bisschen den Weg geebnet und hoffentlich kommen die anderen danach und verkomplettieren dann sozusagen das musikalische Angebot und das Spektrum.
Es gibt ja auch schon erstaunliche Infrastrukturen rund um die Netlabels. Vielleicht mal so die Podcasting-Welt. Also was auf jeden Fall erwähnenswertes Projekt ist, ist hier Starfrosch.ca. Das ist heute auch herkömmlich was.
Der war auch da.
Die machen das ja auch schon sehr lange. Starfrosch ist, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, im Prinzip nichts anderes als eine große Musikschleuder.
MP3-Blog sagt man ja auch, im weitesten Sinne.
Könnte man das nennen. Es ist sozusagen ein automatischer Podcast. Es wird Musik in verschiedenen Genres und Kategorien eingestellt. Man kann das einfach als Podcast abonnieren und dann kommt das einfach so reingepfechert.
Das kann man zum Beispiel auf dem Pulsaren und ich glaube auch bei Pentagonik. Man kann das Ganze auch als Podcast. Das wäre mal eine nächste Frage gewesen. Hast du die neuesten Tracks des Pulsaren oder die Charts oder wie auch immer?
Also technisch ist es ja kein großer Aufwand, wenn man programmieren kann.
Ja, nee, das ist in der Tat.
Also auch exponiert auf dem Pulsaren ist wirklich auf jeder Seite ist oben ein kleiner Podcast-Button und da drückst du drauf und dann hast du alle Tracks, die eben gerade zu sehen sind, die kriegst du dann direkt als Podcast auch. Kannst du natürlich auch abonnieren.
Das ist doch gut. Weil ich denke, das ergänzt dich ganz gut. Zumal ja auch, darauf wollte ich nämlich eigentlich hinaus. Podcasting ist ja dann wiederum so ein bisschen das Äquivalent. Wir haben vorhin schon über Blogger gesprochen, die immer alles so schön kostenlos machen und das einfach mit Herz und Liebe dabei sind. Beim Podcasting ist es ja dasselbe. Das ist im Prinzip die Leute, die gerne Radio machen wollen, ohne dafür jetzt bezahlt zu werden. Also hier so einsame Gestalten wie ich. In meinem Zimmerchen irgendwie. Es heilt ein bisschen. Das Baby schreit. Und man hat auch seine Technik immer nur im Ansatz ein bisschen im Griff. Aber auch da steckt natürlich ein bisschen was dahinter. Weil man versucht natürlich auch das Format so zu machen, wie man es eben machen möchte. Mit der Länge, die man braucht, mit der Ungezwungenheit, mit der man es braucht. Und ich denke, das lässt sich genauso gut auf Musik übersetzen. Und jetzt gibt es natürlich da auch übergreifende Sachen. Weil in zunehmendem Maße wird es Leute geben, die über Podcasts wirklich unterhaltsame Sendungen machen. Und natürlich da auch Musik brauchen. Dann kommen wir nämlich auch schon zum nächsten leidlichen Thema. Nämlich die Frage der Lizenzen. Man weiß ja am Anfang schon gesagt, die Musik muss frei sein. Frei im Sinne von... Frei Bier. Man zahlt nichts dafür. Aber auch frei im Sinne von, man ist frei, es zu nutzen. Ihr verwendet alle Creative Commons Lizenzen.
Das hat sich mittlerweile auch durchgesetzt in der Netlabel-Szene, dass die Allermeisten sich der CC-Lizenz bedienen.
Heißt das, dass ihr jetzt nur eine einzige Lizenz verwendet für alles oder dass jeder direkt da separat lizenziert wird?
Jeder hat gleich lizenziert. Das ist die BY, also NC und ND, also Namensnennung, dann keine kommerzielle Nutzung und keine Bearbeitung.
Also mit anderen Worten darfst du nehmen, darfst du kopieren, darfst du weitersenden, aber darfst du nicht irgendwie als Basis für neue Musik verwenden. Und nicht kommerziell nutzen.
Vor allem kann nicht kommerziell nutzen bzw. wenn du uns vorher fragst, das ist was anderes.
Na klar, aber die Lizenz geht ja für den Fall, wo man nicht fragt.
Genau.
Und bei Pulsar?
Ähnlich. Da ist es so, dass jeder Musiker auch noch darüber hinaus dann entscheiden kann, wie das jetzt bei einem bestimmten Titel ist, ob er den jetzt unter einer anderen Lizenz einstellen will. Aber es besteht eben die Ansage, dass soweit nicht abweichend angegeben sind alle Tracks unter dieser Lizenz.
Das ist ja eigentlich so die minimale Version. Das ist so das Minimum im Creative Commons Werkzeugkasten, Lizenz-Baukasten. Was hält jetzt die Leute davon ab, zum Beispiel zu sagen, die Rivetiffs sind jetzt erlaubt, also man darf jetzt auch darauf aufbauend neue Musik machen?
Da spricht nichts dagegen. Wie gesagt, auf dem Besan könnt ihr das auch für jeden Track einzeln entscheiden.
Aber wird das auch gemacht?
Es wird dann weniger gemacht, indem der Track dann als solches bezeichnet wird, sondern dann passiert es eigentlich eher untereinander, dass die Musiker zueinander Kontakt aufnehmen und dann sagen, ich würde gerne deinen Track weiter bearbeiten. Und dann macht es ja auch Sinn, das nicht mit einer fertiggemasterten Version zu machen, sondern dann wollen die ja sowieso meistens die Spuren haben. Im Zweifelsfall ist es in dem Fall, also es macht keinen großen Unterschied, weil selbst wenn ich das jetzt als Derivat nutzen darf, dann ist es ja nur dann wirklich interessant für mich als Musiker, wenn ich eben was ich, die Kickdrum, auch dann rauslassen kann oder hier nur das Vocal nehme oder das Ganze dann nochmal komplett neu auslese.
Aber als Podcaster frage ich mich dann so, was ist denn, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie zwei Tracks gleichzeitig spiele und so eine interaktive Musikcollage mache, verstoße ich dann schon gegen die Rizenz?
Ja, das wird oft diskutiert, wie das in Mixen ist. In Net-Audio-Mixen oder so. Das ist ja auch eine gewisse Bearbeitung. Das kann man ja auch schon so als Radio.
Aber da fehlen wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen die Präzedenzfälle. Definitiv. Also so ein bisschen wurde das ja auch noch nie ausgefochten. Also wenn ich jetzt nicht falsch informiert bin, dann hat auch noch nie jemand wirklich jetzt eine Klage angestrengt auf Grundlage der Creative Commons-Lizenz, dass er jetzt irgendwie...
Na es gab schon, aber nicht aufgrund dieser keine Bearbeitung...
Mehr wegen dieser No-Commercial-Geschichte. Da gab es einen Fall hier.
Da ist aber auch ganz schwierig, die Grenzlinien zu ziehen, muss man auch dazu sagen.
Das denke ich auch.
Weil gerade jetzt, wenn wir zum Beispiel von der Netlag sprechen, die ja auf keinen Fall ein kommerzielles Projekt ist, soll wir eigentlich unsere ganzen Einnahmen auch wieder zurückgeben an die Artis. Aber auch da ist es streng genommen so, dass wenn man das ganz streng auslegt, dann nehmen wir Eintritt. Und es ist eben so, dass von manchen vielleicht dann auch fehlinterpretiert wird als kommerzielle Veranstaltung. Das heißt, da wäre es dann auch an der Zeit, das Ganze mal so ein bisschen zu spezifizieren und da vielleicht wirklich ganz klar auch zu sagen, was ist denn eine kommerzielle Nutzung. Also da ist auf jeden Fall meiner Meinung nach noch so eine kleine Grauzone innerhalb dieser ganzen Creative Commons Lizenz, dass manche Szenarien der Benutzung nicht wirklich bis ins Letzte durchdekliniert wurden.
Ja, ich glaube, es gibt natürlich auch die Fälle, wo es klar ist, was weiß ich jetzt, so Werbung oder so. Wie ist denn eure Musik, also abgesehen davon, dass Leute das runterhören, weil sie sich für Musik an sich interessieren, weil sie selber DJs sind oder einfach nur begeisterte Fans sind. Gibt es denn noch andere Nutzungen von dem Musikmaterial, was ihr bereitstellt? Sind schon mal Firmen auf euch zugekommen und haben dann wirklich auch für eine kommerzielle Nutzung gefragt?
Independent-Filme, also eher so im Home-Production-Bereich, die haben wir uns schon mal angefragt. Die laufen dann auch gleich in den Filmen. Ich finde das sogar gut. Wir helfen denen dann auch mit Absprache der jeweiligen Künstler. Helfen wir denen ja dann auch, im Prinzip, bekannter zu werden. Und es bringt uns natürlich auch einen gewissen Gewinn, weil es muss halt eine Namensnennung schon mit drin sein. Für beide Personen auf jeden Fall. Aber sollte es jetzt mal dazu kommen, dass wir unseren Track in einer BMW-Werbung sehen, dann läuft irgendwas falsch.
Oder VW oder Mercedes-Benz.
Ja, aber wir sind ja nicht im öffentlichen Recht. Das ist ja egal.
Weil die dürfen Automarken auch ausgelassen werden.
Zur Thematik, beim Pulsaren ist es auch so. Das ist jetzt zum Beispiel ein aktuelles Beispiel. Es wurde ein Film von Greenpeace vertonen, mit einem Track vom Pulsaren. Dieses Jahr war auch der Karneval der Kulturen der Trailer dazu. Der wurde auch von zwei Tracks untermalt, die von Pulsar-Artists bereitgestellt wurden. Also non-kommerzielle Anfragen gab es derart schon viele. Kommerzielle Anfragen bisher auf dem Pulsaren auch noch nicht.
Du hast vorhin schon mal erwähnt, so Musikbeschallungen in Cafés oder so.
Das wäre zum Beispiel auf jeden Fall ein ganz interessanter Markt, glaube ich, allgemein für die Netlabels-Szene. Und ich denke mal, da ist auch...
Weil derzeit müssen ja die Cafés, wenn sie Musik laufen lassen, sich dann mit der GEMA auseinander setzen.
Mit der GEMA rumplagen, ja. Und teilweise auch wirklich nicht unerhebliche Mengen an finanziellen Zuwendungen dann der GEMA zukommen lassen.
Hast du da irgendeine Ahnung, was so ein Café so dafür auffällt?
Das kommt auf den Durchlauf an und kommt auch auf die Größe und auf die Anzahl der Sitzplätze und so weiter an. Also genau bin ich da nicht in Bilder.
An den Durchlauf, also sozusagen...
Ja, wie viele Gäste die haben.
Wirklich.
Also es ist auch wirklich... Ich kenne einen Fall von einem Theater in Potsdam, wo der Betreiber wirklich durch die GEMA-Gebühren mehr oder weniger seinen Betrieb aufgeben musste, weil in den Pausen eben immer mal wieder Musik eingespielt wird. Und er aufgrund einfach nur dieser Einspielung in den Theaterpausen und aufgrund der Größe des Theaters, das eben irgendwie 250 oder 260 Sitzplätze hat, eben zu GEMA-Gebühren verdonnert wurde, die...
So nachträglich kann er so ein Brief, hallo, hier spielt er immer der Musik.
Genau, nachträglich kann der Brief. Und der hat letztendlich dann auch den Theaterbetrieb dann zum Erliegen gebracht. Also es geht wirklich so weit, dass eben die Gebühren, die ja wirklich teilweise nicht unerheblich sind, die von der GEMA eingefordert werden, dass die zumindest bei kleineren Projekten durchaus ganz schön ins Gewicht fallen. Das ist ja übrigens auch ein ganz entscheidender Aspekt der Netlag, die wir da ins Leben gerufen haben, die Veranstaltungsreihe, dass wir eben über die Tatsache hinaus, dass wir der Netlabels-Szene in ein größeres Podium verschaffen wollen, eben auch darauf aufmerksam machen möchten, dass die GEMA-Verteilungspolitik eben extrem verfehlt in unseren Augen abläuft. Also es ist so, dass zum Beispiel ein Veranstalter, wenn der eine Party initiiert und im Verlauf des gesamten Abends sich auch nur ein einziger GEMA-pflichtiger Track einschleicht, dass eben die gesamte Veranstaltung GEMA-pflichtig wird. Und das schlägt dann ganz schön ins Gewicht. Auf der anderen Seite wiederum ist die GEMA nicht verpflichtet oder ist auch gar nicht in der Lage, bei ihren gegenwärtigen Verteilungsmechanismen dafür Sorge zu tragen, dass das Geld, was eben eingenommen wird, was ja eigentlich im Auftrag der Künstler eingetrieben wird, dass das auch bei denjenigen landet, die tatsächlich auch gespielt wurden. Es besteht wirklich bei der GEMA-Tantienverteilung die absurde Situation, dass wenn ich als Underground-Veranstalter eine Party mache, bin ich dazu verpflichtet, entweder nachzuweisen, dass es sich komplett um eine GEMA-freie Veranstaltung handelt. Das muss ich dann aber auch anhand von Playlisten nachweisen, die ich dann an die GEMA schicken muss. Oder ich zahle die GEMA-Gebühren, die im Auftrag der Musiker, die eigentlich gespielt werden, an dem Abend erhoben wird. Die GEMA bleibt aber jedem Beweis schuldig, dass die Musiker, die gespielt wurden, eben tatsächlich auch diese Gelder bekommen. Und dann gibt es eben noch dazu diese absurde Unterteilung zwischen E- und U-Musik, wo dann eben manche Musikverlage überproportional stark beteiligt sind. Also ernste Musik und Unterhaltungsmusik. Genau. Es ist eben so, dass die GEMA aus diesem Bereich der U-Musik eben erhebliche Mengen abzwackt und eben in den vermeintlich kulturell wichtigen Bereich der E-Musik umleitet und dadurch aber eben viele kleine Musiker schädigt, die in den Clubs gespielt werden und auch von vielen Menschen geschätzt und gehört werden, die aber trotzdem nie irgendeinen Cent von der GEMA bekommen, obwohl sie bei der GEMA Mitglied sind. Also eigentlich auch das Recht hätten, dass das Geld, was ihnen zustimmt und was ihr zusteht und was die GEMA ja in ihrem Auftrag auch erhebt, dass denen das zugeleitet wird, das passiert aber nicht.
Und sie bekommen dann gar kein Geld?
Sie bekommen dann gar kein Geld.
Also nicht für diesen einen Fall, aber grundsätzlich, wenn man bei der GEMA ist, dann gibt es schon immer irgendeinen Finanzstrom, ne?
Genau, es gibt so einen Verteilungsschlüssel, der aber eben darauf aufgebaut ist, wie lange jemand Mitglied ist, ob er jetzt ein Außerordentliches oder ein Ordentliches oder was weiß ich, was für ein Mitglied ist. Da gibt es ganz viele Unterteilungen. Und diejenigen, die eben ganz oben im Tantiemen-Pod stehen, die bekommen eben auch den Löwenanteil des Geldes, was eingetrieben wird. Da muss man dann auch wieder dazu sagen, so eine gewisse Teilschuld liegt da auch bei den Veranstaltern. Gerade bei kleineren Veranstaltern wäre es eben auch ganz wichtig, dass man Playlisten abgibt bei der GEMA, damit die GEMA überhaupt erst mal dazu übergehen kann, eben auch diese kleineren Arten zu bedenken mit den Tantiemen. Das ist natürlich insgesamt, ändert das nichts an der Ungerechtigkeit des Systems. Aber die kleinen Veranstalter leisten ihren Beitrag dazu, dass es zumindest nicht besser wird.
Aber so einfach ist das glaube ich nicht. Also wie ich das bei meinem Radio mitbekommen habe, ist ja allein dieses Abgeben dieser Playlisten, das grenzt ja schon an Vergewaltigung.
Das ist ja auch, wenn man sich das mal überlegt, du kennst ja auch den Veranstaltungsbereich so ein bisschen. Und es ist einfach nicht praktikabel, dass man von jedem DJ eine Playliste einfordert. Auf der anderen Seite muss man dann aber auch wiederum sagen, bei 860 Millionen Euro Einnahmen, die die GEMA im Jahr 2005 erzielt hat, wäre es glaube ich durchaus denkbar, dass man einen Teil davon in Forschungsprojekte fließen lässt, die eben genau eine solche Abrechnung auch wirklich möglich machen, dass man eben minutiös nachweisen kann, ohne dass jemand, dass ein Scriptgirl hinter dem DJ steht und jeden Track mitschreibt, der gespielt wird.
Ja, ich meine, im Radio gibt es ja automatische Musikerkennung. Wenn man da so eine Blackbox hinstellt auf die Party.
Da wäre dann zum Beispiel ein gewisses Maß an Überwachung, wogegen wir glaube ich hier sonst alle im Raum eher oponieren.
Genau, Vorratenspeicherung jetzt auch für Partys.
Dann soll man doch bitte, wenn man schon überwachen möchte, dann sollte man doch vielleicht dann in die Bereiche vordringen, wo es dann auch wirklich dem dient, dass derjenige, der tatsächlich eine Leistung erbracht hat, die eben dann auch wieder mehr Wert erzeugt, nämlich auf der Party, weil die Leute gehen ja wegen der Musik auf die Partys, dass man doch dann so anständig ist und dem wirklichen Urheber zumindest alle Wege in, also beziehungsweise alle Mittel in Bewegung setzt, um diesem Musiker dann auch das Geld zukommen zu lassen, was ihm zusteht. Das passiert momentan überhaupt nicht. Im Gegenteil, es findet eine Umschichtung von unten nach oben statt, auch mit gewissen Parallelen zu unserer Gesellschaft zu betrachten. Und dagegen wollen wir auch oponieren mit der Netlag. Also es geht auch darum, dass man eben die Öffentlichkeit, die meistens nicht besonders viel mit der GEMA anfangen kann, die vielleicht den Begriff schon mal gehört haben, aber die mit den tatsächlichen Abläufen nicht vertraut sind, dass man da einfach mal darauf aufmerksam macht, dass da ein Zustand ist, der aus Sicht der allermeisten Musiker wirklich unhaltbar ist. Und da spreche ich zum Beispiel auch nicht nur von der elektronischen Musikszene. Ich war jetzt am Samstag als Podiumsgast auf der TBA Musikmesse in Potsdam. TBA heißt die? TBA ist quasi die Abkürzung eines kleinen Wortspiels. Eine sehr interessante Messe auch. Und da habe ich eben erstaunt feststellen müssen, dass eben nicht nur im elektronischen Bereich, am Anfang habe ich mich da so ein bisschen gefühlt wie so ein kleiner Paradiesvogel, weil ich nur von Rockern und dergleichen umgeben war. Und musste aber feststellen, dass die genau die gleichen Ansichten und auch die gleichen Probleme mit der GEMA-Tantiemen-Verteilung haben wie auch die Vertreter der elektronischen Musik sehen. Und ich finde, da ist es auf jeden Fall an der Zeit, dass man da so ein bisschen auch mal das Ganze nach außen trägt. Und diese Problematik...
Es gibt auch immer mehr Musik, die produziert wird.
Die GEMA nimmt auch immer mehr ein zum Beispiel. Und jedes Jahr steigen die Einnahmen auch an von der GEMA. Also unbeachtet von rückläufigen Tonträgerverkäufen. Die GEMA hat sich ja auch hervorgetan durch etwas umstrittene Praktiken auch bei der Vermarktung von Online-Musik. Also da ist es ja zum Beispiel auch so, dass wenn man als Musiker GEMA Mitglied ist und auf seiner eigenen Homepage, wohlgemerkt, kostenfrei Musik anbietet und dass der GEMA nicht vorher sagt, dass man das auch explizit irgendwie aus dem Verwertungskatalog nehmen möchte, dass man dann als Musiker, also dass ich als Schöpfer meiner eigenen Musik, wenn ich sie denn kostenlos anbiete, sogar noch Geld an die GEMA zahlen muss, damit dieser, ich weiß nicht genau wie viel Cent sind, aber es ist gar nicht mal unerheblich, sind also glaube ich 5,5.
Das ist dann auch pro Download, nicht so, dass man das generell darf, sondern wenn das dann wirklich populär ist, muss man auch darunter leiden.
Genau, also das ist wirklich eine absurde Situation, die einfach auch zeigt, wie sehr diejenigen, die eben in der GEMA Verantwortung tragen, sich eigentlich komplett auch aus der Realität, die eben die Musiker beschäftigt verabschiedet haben. Also da muss dringend auch eine Veränderung her. Und wenn man sich alleine mal auf der GEMA-Homepage anschaut, wer denn da die Verantwortlichen sind, dann kann man schon so ein bisschen auch an den Gesichtern erkennen, dass das nicht unbedingt diejenigen sind, die vielleicht zum Beispiel sich um eine florierende Clubszene unbedingt gerne verdient machen möchten, sondern dass es da wahrscheinlich eher darum geht, Besitzstände zu wahren, die man in den letzten Jahrzehnten angehäuft hat und die meiner Meinung nach einfach abseits von jeglicher Raison im Musikbereich dann erhoben werden. Also gerade aus der Clubszene findet zum Beispiel wirklich ein erheblicher Geldabfluss statt in die Bereiche der E-Musikszene. Also in die Bereiche der E-Musik und das ist eigentlich nicht hinnehmbar. Also das ist ja sowieso ein Bereich, der eigentlich schon, wo wirklich sehr knapp kalkuliert werden muss von vielen Clubbetreibern zumindest, nicht gerade von den Großen, aber...
E-Musik, damit meinen wir ja so klassische Musik, Konzerte, die ohnehin eigentlich schon subventioniert sind in der Regel. Opern.
So sieht es aus. Und die bekommen eben dann zusätzlich noch den Löwenanteil des Tantiemenkuchens von der GEMA ab und das ist untragbar.
Den Löwenanteil? Gibt es da einen Schlüsselinfaktor, den du am Kopf hast? Gibt es aber.
Ich kann zum Beispiel eine zahlen, denn es sind 5% der GEMA-Mitglieder, die 50% der Einnahmen erhalten. Also das ist schon erheblich.
Kann man nicht sagen, dass dann vielleicht auch diese 5% zu 50% gehört werden? Ich meine, dann würde das ja gerechtfertigt sein.
Naja, so ist es ja nicht. Wenn man das mal zahlenmäßig vergleicht, dann sind die Konzertbesuche klassischer Musik und auch die Verkaufszahlen an klassischen Alben...
Du beziehst dich jetzt nur auf E-Musik oder was?
Ja, das ist aber auch einfach die Klientel, die am oberen Ende der GEMA-Verteilungsschlüssel am meisten profitiert. Das ist Fakt. Und nebenbei gesagt ist es eben auch so, dass ich als Underground-Veranstalter, auf dessen Party, was weiß ich, Sweet and Candy und Tobi Dreher und was weiß ich, was läuft, wenn ich keine Playliste abgebe, wird im Zweifelsfall dann eben an die E-Musik-Fraktion und eben auch an die Charts-Musiker das Geld ausgeschüttet, die eben auch ordentliche Mitglieder der GEMA sind und dadurch eben auch einen höheren Prozentsatz ausgeschüttet bekommen.
Weil sie davon ausgehen, wenn du irgendwie deine Party machst, dann kommen die Leute hin, Modern Talking.
Dann läuft da automatisch Scooter und DJ Ötzi und was weiß ich was. Das heißt, ich subventioniere den nächsten Sportwagen, plakativ gesagt von Scooter und DJ Ötzi mit meiner Party, weil ich die GEMA-Gebühren abdrücken muss und die eben keineswegs da wieder zurückfließen an die Musiker, die auf meiner Party gespielt werden.
Aber wenn du eine Playlist abgibst, ändert das auch nichts daran, oder?
Das ändert dann zumindest ein bisschen was daran, weil dann eben dieser...
Es gibt einen Einfluss auf diese...
Es gibt einen Einfluss auf das System. Und es gibt eben auch dann einen gewissen, wenn auch unterproportionalen Rückfluss zu dem Musiker, der dann eben auch GEMA-Mitglied ist. Also das ist wirklich ein ganz komplexer Themenbereich. Da könnten wir jetzt auch noch stundenlang drüber philosophieren.
Ich hab vor kurzem, hat sich ein Künstler bei uns beworben aus Kanada. Das ist die Verwertungsgesellschaft, heißt da die Sokarn, so irgendwie. Und da war es natürlich auch erstmal das Standardproblem, dass Künstler die sich halt irgendwie bei uns bewerben, dass wir erstmal schauen müssen, sind die denn nun GEMA-Mitglieder? Also irgendwie alle unsere, zumindest bei Pentagonik und bei euch auch, sind die, die sind nicht GEMA-Mitglieder.
Genau, das ist Grundvoraussetzung.
Muss man auch dazu sagen, bei der GEMA ist man ja sozusagen leibeigen. Also man ist ja als Person da drin und man schließt nicht für einzelne Musiktracks Vertreter.
Also es gibt einen sogenannten Wahrnehmungsvertrag und der schließt alle Werke ein, die du jemals, soweit ich weiß, auch rückwirkend, komponiert hast.
Das ist zum Beispiel auch diese Rückwirkung. Das ist auch ein total absurder Gesichtspunkt, weil er einfach mal die Rechtssicherheit, die eigentlich in unserem Rechtsstaat verbrieft ist, grundsätzlich in Frage stellt. Also wenn ich jetzt einen Track zum Beispiel auf dem Pulsaren habe von einem Musiker, der nicht bei der GEMA ist, der aber irgendwann mal in die GEMA eintritt, dann wird dieser Track rückwirkend auch GEMA-pflichtig, obwohl dieser Track zuerst bei mir angeboten wurde. Und im Endeffekt bin ich womöglich dann...
Sogar noch zahlungspflichtig....
in der Situation, dass ich womöglich dann mich dafür noch rechtfertigen muss, warum denn dieser Track da bei mir steht, obwohl er zuerst bei mir war, bevor er jemals bei der GEMA gemeldet hat. Also da gibt es wirklich einige Sachen, die sehr im Argen liegen. Das Problem ist eben auch, dass die GEMA einfach ein Monopol hat in unserem Staat und eben dazu auch zur Erhebung dieser Gebühren berechtigt ist.
Jedenfalls war das dann das Problem, dass er sich ja ganz normal oder beziehungsweise war es erstmal nicht das Problem, dass er sich beworben hatte. Aber wir mussten zunächst erstmal herausfinden, ob er, als wir uns dann gesagt hatten, Mitglied der SOKAN, die Verwertungsgesellschaft in Kanada, in irgendeiner Art Kontakt hat zur GEMA. Das klingt auf jeden Fall merkwürdig. Da war auf jeden Fall sehr viel Recherche im Vorfeld zu tun. Wir haben dann herausgefunden, dass bei der SOKAN so ist, dass du einzelne Tracks aus deiner Verwertung ausschließen kannst. Da sind da der GEMA schon einiges voraus. Das heißt, du kannst explizit sagen, dieser Track läuft ausschließlich nur unter Creative Commons. Das bedeutet für mich, er läuft unter einer freien Lizenz und hat nichts mit einer Verwertung in Kanada zu tun.
Da muss man auch sagen, dass die GEMA im internationalen Vergleich gesehen sehr rückständig ist.
Das wird mir gerade erst klar. Das heißt ja auch, dass man als GEMA-Musiker noch nicht mal zwischendurch was Freies der Öffentlichkeit schenken kann.
Singen darf.
Ach so, man darf noch nicht mal frei singen.
Das könnte ja als öffentliche Darbietung deklariert werden.
Für Podcasts haben sie ja auch letztes Jahr, glaube ich, mal so Vorschläge gemacht, wie man denn da so mit GEMA-Musik usw.
Was ist daraus geworden?
Ich fand das, das war allein schon deshalb indiskutabel, ich weiß von niemandem, der das gemacht hat, heißt aber nicht, dass es das nicht auch gibt. Aber ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen, weil es ist halt auch so, nicht nur, dass du dann irgendwie so einen Betrag zahlst pro Monat, es kommen dann wieder alle möglichen Sachen rein, wie häufig sendest du, wie lange usw., aber dann auch so absurde Sachen wie, wenn du die Musik dann verwendest, dann darfst du sie aber nicht ganz ausspielen. Man muss da vielleicht noch drüber moderieren. Also Zwänge bis in das Format hinein, das geht natürlich schon mal überhaupt nicht. Ich bin ja vollkommen bereit, da über irgendeine Lizenzzahlung, würde ich jetzt GEMA Musik verwenden, auch noch zu reden. Aber dass das dann erstmal sich so an so einem regelmäßigen Erscheinungsding, was für Podcasts sowieso Quatsch ist, festmacht, bzw. dann eben auch noch mir vorschreibt, wie ich konkret die Musik da reinzumixen habe. Alles mal ausgehend von so einem normalen Dudelfunkradio. Ich denke, die sind auch einfach an der Stelle, wo sie innovationsbereit sind, wo sie vielleicht auch einsehen, da müsste man eigentlich mal was tun, da peilen sie es dann einfach auch nicht. Da sind sie auch zu paranoid.
Das ist auch dann wahrscheinlich sehr komplex für viele Entscheidungsträger, zu verstehen, wie was läuft. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie sich irgendwann mal ein Chaosradio Express angehört haben.
Bestimmt nicht. Aber ich denke, die haben einfach Angst, sich da irgendeine Zukunftstechnologie einzutreten, die sie dann nicht wieder loswerden. Deswegen bleiben sie lieber bei dem, was sie haben, damit sie wissen, was sie zu verteidigen haben.
Aber grundsätzlich muss man ja dazu auch immer noch sagen, die Grundidee ist ja tatsächlich auch gut, dass die Künstler da Geld bekommen für eine Verwertung.
Genau. Und auch für eine pauschale Nutzung.
Wie es abläuft, ist tatsächlich einfach nicht tragbar.
Es geht ja auch nicht grundsätzlich darum, dass man in Situationen wie die GEMA abschaffen möchte, sondern dass man sie erstens auf die Höhe der Zeit bringt und auf der anderen Seite diese Ungerechtigkeiten, die sich da eingeschliffen haben, einfach beseitigt.
Kennt ihr die Diskussion um die Kultur-Flatrate? Ja. Habt ihr euch da mal mit auseinandergesetzt?
Gleiches Problem. Das wird dann wahrscheinlich auf die gleiche Thematik hinauslaufen. Solange es nicht möglich ist, das Ganze gerecht zu verteilen, dann die Mittel, die dann eingenommen werden, wird es genauso ein Subventionierungssystem werden, wie die GEMA es heute schon ist. Also ich bin da sehr skeptisch. Grundsätzlich finde ich die Idee nicht schlecht und auch die Diskussion nicht schlecht. Wie ich ja vorher auch schon gesagt habe, ich würde mir auch wünschen, dass eben ein größerer Prozentsatz der Internet-User eben durchaus nicht mehr vielleicht gewahr wird des Wertes der Leistung, die sie eben in Anspruch nehmen. Auf der anderen Seite bin ich gegen eine solche pauschale Gebühr, weil man, wie man bei der GEMA auch schon sieht, die Gebühr zu erheben alleine, trägt eben zunächst mal überhaupt gar nicht zu einer gerechteren Welt bei, sondern im Gegenteil, unter Umständen führt das eben zu genau so einer Subventionssteuer, die eben dann diejenigen begünstigt, die es eigentlich gar nicht nötig haben und die auch sonst schon ganz gut über die Runden kommen. Und die Befürchtung sehe ich eben sehr stark bei der Kultur-Flatrate.
Was ich vor allem sehe, ist, dass es einfach auch nicht mit der Nutzung skaliert. Also da ist mal über 5 Euro im Monat geredet worden von irgendwelchen Internet-Usern. Das begrenzt dann den Pool nach unten und nach oben. Und das ist natürlich dann auch blöd, weil wenn jetzt mal wirklich irgendwas populär ist. Also ich denke, ja, die Dienstleistung. Also Partys als Dienstleistung für ein Netlabel, finde ich ja, passt irgendwie ganz gut.
Gutes Beispiel gibt es von Archipel. Die haben Tracks kostenpflichtig angeboten. Und nach drei Monaten sind sie dann frei sozusagen.
Ja, Zeitverzögerung.
Ja, genau, so war es. Ich finde so eine Idee sehr viel interessanter und kreativer. Also es müssten eigentlich noch sehr viel mehr Ideen kommen. Wir haben es bei der Netlag versucht, dass das Geld direkt an die Künstler geht.
Es gibt so einen Port von dieser freien Software Open Office für den Mac, für die es halt keine offizielle Unterstützung gab. Da gab es so ein kleines Team, die haben das halt gemacht. Die haben gesagt, okay, alles klar, neue Version ist fertig, könnt ihr jetzt kaufen. Oder ihr könnt noch vier Wochen warten oder so. Es gab dann auch irgendeinen Zeitraum. Und dann kann sich sowieso jeder runterladen.
Super Idee, weil man ja dann auch noch dem Rechnung trägt, dass diejenigen, die professionell mit irgendwas arbeiten, das dann wahrscheinlich tendenziell auch gleich haben wollen. Und die sind auch eher bereit und in der Lage dazu, dann auch ein bisschen Geld dafür abzudrücken. Während diejenigen, die das vielleicht nur privat für sich zu Hause nutzen, für die ist es nicht so wichtig, ob es jetzt die alle neuesten Feature haben. Und die können dann eben auch durchaus noch ein paar Wochen warten. Also ich finde solche Modelle...
Genau, da wird auch die eigentliche Dienstleistung der Distribution honoriert. Also dass wirklich jemand sich die Mühe macht, es bereitzustellen, das ist vielleicht so ein Ansatz an der Stelle. Und so Live-Performances ist ja auch immer wieder so eine Sache. Also ich habe so einige Musiker gesprochen, die jetzt auch eher so mit GEMA-Vertrag unterwegs sind, die auch ein paar erfolgreiche CDs gehabt haben. Gibt es so ein paar in meinem Umfeld. Kennt ihr sicherlich auch, aber ich will jetzt mal keinen Namen nennen. Auf jeden Fall hat sich da auch so der Trend abgezeichnet, dass für die Erfolgreicheren auch die Partys bzw. die Live-Auftritte auch immer interessanter werden.
Das ist auch allgemein erkennbar in der Musikbranche. Der signifikante Rückgang der Tonträgerverkäufe geht einher mit einem starken Anstieg der Einnahmen durch Konzerte und Auftritte. Das sieht man. Es ist sogar so, dass dieser Zuwachs an Konzertticketverkäufen diesen Rückgang bei den Tonträgerverkäufen mehr als ausgleicht. Also eigentlich auch dieser Klagegesang der Musikindustrie, der ist eben einfach auch Fehlernplatzer, weil das Gesamtbild betrachtet, wird so viel Geld für Musik ausgegeben wie nie zuvor. Es ist einfach nur so, dass diejenigen, die in der Vergangenheit so stark davon profitiert haben, nämlich die Musikmajors und diejenigen, die die Tonträger verkauft und vertrieben haben, dass die eben nicht mehr so ein großes Stück vom Kuchen abkriegen und sich das dann eher so ein bisschen in die Richtung der Konzertpromoter und auch der Bands, die auch stärker partizipieren können, eben bei Auftritten im Vergleich zu Tonträgerverkäufen. Wenn man das mal ausrechnet, ist das eine ganz einfache Rechnung. Ich stelle es jetzt einfach mal so in den Raum. Zum Beispiel beim Tonträgerverkauf landet vielleicht 10 Prozent des tatsächlichen Umsatzes dann beim Musiker und bei den Konzertpromotern. Die geben 40 bis 50 Prozent dann an die Musiker ab. Da kann man sehen, dass das viel interessanter für den Musiker ist. Ich glaube auch, dass die Musiker in Zukunft, wenn man das Ganze dann auch tonträgerungebundener vertreiben kann und dadurch keine so hohen Kosten hat, wie wenn man einfach mal die CD in den Handel bringen muss. Da muss man auch dazu sagen, dass der Handel auch derjenige ist, der die CD-Preise doch ganz erheblich in die Höhe treibt. Das darf man auch nicht vergessen. Worauf wollte ich hinaus? Das Live.
Dass Live einen größeren Anteil hat und dass die Dienstleistung mehr im Vordergrund steht.
Genau. Und in Zukunft kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass der Vertrieb von Musik weitestgehend kostenfrei ablaufen kann. Und ich mir als Musiker dann sage, es ist ja schön, wenn möglichst viele Leute meine Musik hören. Eine bessere Promotion als die kostenlose gibt es sowieso gar nicht. Also wenn sich jeder die Musik kostenlos runterladen kann, trägt das auch auf jeden Fall zu einer Steigerung meines Bekanntheitsgrades bei. Und diesen Effekt kann ich dann eben als positiven Spin-off-Effekt einfach auch auf meine Live-Karriere übertragen und habe dann diesen gesteigerten Bekanntheitsgrad, wo mir vielleicht erstmal Geld flöten gegangen ist, weil ich keine Tonträger verkauft habe, kann den aber wieder um Münzen in eine erfolgreiche Tournee oder erfolgreiche Live-Auftritte in Clubs oder dergleichen. Und dadurch habe ich dann einfach diesen Effekt wieder ausgeglichen. Und am Ende stehe ich womöglich als Musiker besser da, als am Anfang, wo ich viele Tonträger verkauft habe, aber dann eben auch zugucken konnte, wie sich alle möglichen Leute dieses Geld zum größten Teil in die Taschen gesteckt haben.
Da schließt sich jetzt so ein bisschen der Kreis, weil ich aber am Anfang gesagt habe, naja, ist das jetzt so ein bisschen die Zukunft? Weil wenn das so ist, dann heißt es ja, dass eigentlich die Labelarbeit sehr viel mehr in den Bereich Promotion geht und sehr viel größeres Interesse daran hat, möglichst viele Leute zu erreichen. Das möglichst einfach. Da ist natürlich das Netlabel im Prinzip nichts anderes als der Prototyp. Wenn man das dann wiederum paart mit Veranstaltungen, wie es ja eigentlich auch schon macht, wenn auch nicht so in den Dimensionen von Madonna.
Sollen wir ja auch gar nicht.
Könnte das so ein Weg sein. Haben Sie noch andere Dienstleistungskonzepte, die so besprochen wurden, vielleicht auf der Konferenz, die da noch greifen könnten?
Na ja, ein Aspekt war, wie eben schon angesprochen, auch die Vertonung von Filmmaterial. Da ist ja durchaus auch eventuell in Zukunft ein Markt vorhanden, weil man eben durchaus feststellt, dass da ein gesteigertes Interesse herrscht und auch im Bereich der Hintergrundbeschallung. Eben auch, wie vorhin schon mal angesprochen, Cafés, dergleich mehr. Ich glaube, das sind wirklich so die Kernbereiche.
Ja, da ist auch genau wieder dieses Problem mit der kommerziellen Nutzung. Wie verträgt sich das mit den Creative Commons Lizenzen?
Also ich glaube, wenn jemand einen Café betreibt und im Hintergrund Musik dudeln lässt, dann ist das kaum als wirklich kommerzielle Nutzung eigentlich so zu verstehen.
Na gut, die GEMA sieht das anders.
Ja, natürlich sieht die GEMA das anders. Aber ich würde mir da eigentlich in der Situation dann eher. Sorgen, wenn dann eben wirklich Geld in erheblichem Maße fließt, dass man das dann eben wirklich dann wieder dem Musiker zukommen lässt. Durch einen gerechten Verteilungs-Schlüssel wäre das ja auch durchaus möglich. Da müsste man sich überlegen, was die Zukunft bringt und welche Entwicklungen da sich abzeichnen.
Okay, ich würde sagen, jetzt machen wir nochmal eine kleine Musikpause, bevor wir hier ins Finale einschreiten. Jetzt haben wir hier noch was von Pädagogik. Soll ich hier von oben die Liste nochmal die Nummer 2 machen?
Das ist von Kai Ross, auch ein Mitbegründer von uns. Oder Kai ist sein richtiger Name. Seit Anfang an dabei. Ein begnadeter Musiker, muss ich schon mal sagen. Auch wenn er sich immer sehr viel Zeit lässt. Ein Perfektionist, schlechthin. Aber was dabei rauskommt, sind wir alle super zufrieden.
So, die Sendung klingt und sie klingt vor allem langsam aus. Jetzt haben wir ja schon eine ganze Menge, ich lass das jetzt mal hier ein bisschen mal laufen, so wie wir das früher mal gemacht haben mit Mucke, Hintergrund. Ja, jetzt haben wir ja nun einen großen Roundup schon gemacht hier. Ich denke, man kriegt schon einen ganz guten Einblick, wie es so ist zu Netlabeln. Was steht denn an? Was ist denn so der Ausblick? Geht es denn weiter mit der Zukunft? Gibt es einen?
Also ich habe jetzt auf dem NetAuto-Festival gute Kontakte geknüpft zu der ganzen italienischen Mannschaft, die ja vorhin schon erwähnt, ist die da so eine sehr lockere Art haben, mit umzugehen. Also das bedingt sich unter anderem deswegen auch, weil in der elektronischen Szene da ziemlich viel schlechte Musik herrscht. Also sprich billige Hausmusik, sagten sie mir, da treffe ich mich wahrscheinlich auch heute Abend noch mal mit einem Künstler, der ja auch gerade in Berlin ist.
Der auch billige Hausmusik macht.
Der macht nicht billige Hausmusik, deswegen bin ich auch interessiert.
Heute Abend, da sieht man wieder mal gleich, wie die Arbeitszeiten von Musikern und Partsbetreibern sind. Wir haben es jetzt halb elf.
Nein, ich würde auch ganz gerne ins Bett gehen, damit ich morgen früh aufstehe und wieder arbeite.
Das ist jetzt späterer Nachmittag.
Genau, ich habe gerade mit Timor gefrühstückt. Da gibt es eine interessante Szene, weil die einen bestimmten Bedarf haben. Da sind auch Netlabels dann gefragt. Gute Musik ist da gefragt und vor allem schnell gute Musik zu produzieren. Zu denen werde ich jetzt auch engeren Kontakt aufnehmen, wenn ich als erste DJ-Austausche starte. Die spielen von den DJs bei uns und umgekehrt. Und einen Release wird es auch geben von denen. Das finde ich persönlich unheimlich interessant. Da kommt man auch endlich mal raus aus Friddezheim und Kreuzberg. Berlin Friddezheim und Berlin Kreuzberg. Das ist eine interessante Sache, finde ich. Und ich werde versuchen, in jedem Interview zu sagen, dass ich ein Jazz-Netlabel haben will.
Was gibt es noch für Ressourcen, die man nennen sollte, für Leute, die Interesse haben, Netlabels zu kommunizieren? Eure beiden Sites haben wir jetzt schon besprochen.
Neben den Netlabels gibt es auch Mix-Labels. Das war es vorhin schon erwähnt. Mix-Sotik-Net hieß früher Zerinnerung.
Das habe ich schon häufiger verwendet.
Es macht schon ewig Net-Audio-Mixer. Sie sind auf einem qualitativ sehr hohen Niveau. Da kann man sich frei herunterladen. Das ist eine Mix-Sotik-Net. Dann einen Franzosen, DJ Lambrouille, der auch auf einem Netlabel bei uns gespielt hat.
Das ist ein totales Tier, oder?
Das ist ein Tier, aber auch eine sehr witzige Geschichte. Der lebt in einem französischen Hinterdorf. Hinterdorf?
Nicht nur ein Dorf, sondern sogar ein Hinterdorf.
Das ist eigentlich ein Kaff sozusagen. Dem ist es viel wichtiger, mit seiner Familie da in dem Dorf weltweit Mixe zu produzieren. Er kriegt ständig Anfragen aus der ganzen Welt für Bookings. Oft ist es ihm einfach wichtiger, damit seine Familie und sein Job so irgendwie. Das ist einer der bekanntesten Net-Audio-DJs. Den kenne ich ja sogar. Da lohnt es sich auf jeden Fall mal reinzuhören, aber der hat irgendwie Qualitativ.
Das ist der, der immer diesen Timothée Leary-Zitat gleich am Anfang seines Mixes einspielt.
Genau, sehr sympathisch. Als ich den getroffen habe, super sympathisch. Ein bisschen vorlaufen lassen, aber das war nicht der einzige.
War der auch auf der Konferenz?
Der war auch da. Das war ein Highlight, den mal zu treffen.
Wir hatten den mal in London. Auf dem NetAudio-Festival 06. Da habe ich den schon kennenlernen dürfen.
In London gibt es auch NetAudio-Festivals.
Das war davor.
Die haben wir auch mitgewirkt. Es war sehr angenehm, weil eine relativ große Fraktion von der Clique, die wir letztes Jahr beim NetAudio-Festival 06 in London kennengelernt haben, in geballter Mannschaft auch nach Berlin angereist ist. Es war schön, da gleich eine Brücke zu schlagen, zu dem NetAudio-Festival im letzten Jahr.
Also, sowohl organisatorisch als auch vom Inhalt her. Der Betreiber vom letzten Jahr hat auch einen Vortrag gehalten, der Andi Studer, und hat auch mit dir zusammen die Main-Discussion geleitet. Also, es war auf jeden Fall optimal. Dann sollte man auf jeden Fall noch erwähnen, es ist Flow. phlow.de. flow.de. Oder net.
Das Magazin für Netzkulturen.
Genau.
Die gibt es auch in gedruckt. Oder gibt es die nur online?
Ich glaube bisher nur noch.
Aber einen Blog haben die oder so was. Einen Podcast haben die glaube ich sogar auch.
Das ist der Moritz Sauer.
Das müsste ich eigentlich besser wissen.
Den hast du bestimmt auch schon mal auf einigen Konferenzen gesehen. Es gibt auch oft Vorträge der Moritz Sauer. Das ist auch so ein ganz netter Filter. Und natürlich die Debug. Genau. Also das Magazin für zeitgenössische Musik.
Die auch einen Podcast haben, aber der ist kaum konsumierbar, weil da fällt so viel Zeug raus. Das macht einen total fertig.
Vier Schrott drin.
Er ist vor allem auch viel und nicht wirklich super sortiert. Was mir dann auch einfällt, wo wir noch bei Podcasts sind, kennt ihr Machtdose. Das ist auch so ein schönes monatliche Netlabel-Zusammenschnitt. Das hat irgendwie ein, zwei Mal sein Konzept geändert, aber das ist auch sehr viel breiter. Also das ist beileibe nicht nur der elektronische Teil, den er abdeckt. Das ist in der Hinsicht glaube ich auch ganz interessant.
Ach so, genau. Und dann noch Kreislauf FM. Das ist natürlich auch aus Hamburg ein Radio. Und der war auch bei uns auch ein Vortrag gehalten. Ein richtiges Radio. Der überträgt auch auf Tee der FM in Hamburg live.
Das heißt, der macht da eine Sendung auf einem anderen Sender?
Macht live und gleichzeitig im Netz eine Sendung.
Aber jetzt nicht so ein 24 Stunden?
Nee, einmal.
Und so ein richtiges Radio, was nur Netlabels Sound bringt, gibt es gar nicht?
Das gibt es noch nicht.
Zurzeit nicht. Da gab es mal was, aber das ist leider nicht mehr online.
Ja, das wäre ja noch mal eine Marktlücke, weil ich höre ja viel und gerne so. Meistens eben so Sommer-FM und ähnliche Projekte, die dann auch, sagen wir mal, schön auch für Dauerbeschallungen sind. Bloß, wenn dann halt mal eine Party angesagt ist, muss man das mal in einem richtigen Kanal finden. Aber das wäre natürlich auch noch ganz interessant.
Um das mal noch so am Rand zu erwähnen, da auf dem Pulsaren ist fast geplant, dass man eben eine regelmäßige Net-Audio-Radiosendung macht, das dann aber nicht wirklich über...
Was willst du denn doch alles machen?
Nicht terrestrische, nicht terrestrische ausgestrahlt, sondern eben hier auf...
Die monatlichen Kosten müssen erhöht werden.
Wieder ein paar Cent mehr.
Ich kauf keinen Trecken mehr.
Ja, und noch mal kurz. Also der Pulsar plant eben im nächsten Jahr auch so einen Relaunch im Juni, eben pünktlich zum Vierjährigen bestehen. Wird das in die ganze Plattform auch nochmal in neuem Gewand erscheinen, sofern ich das denn schaffe, dann auch die Programmiertätigkeit bis dahin abzuschließen.
Ach, programmieren muss das auch alles.
Ja, das ist auch noch zu einem Überfluss. Und um das noch zu erwähnen, vorhin schon mal ganz kurz angesprochen, gibt noch das Spin-off-Label Little Green Man unter lgm1.de zu finden. Das ist eben sozusagen das Pendant zum Pulsaren, wo dann die Chorephäen so ein bisschen aufgerufen werden, da auch noch kostenpflichtig ihre Tracks dann anbieten zu können, um das eben sauber zu trennen, weil ich, also ich wollte das eben nicht machen, dass man eben auf der gleichen Plattform sowohl kostenpflichtiger als auch kostenfrei...
Das ist der Commercial Plug.
Genau, das ist sozusagen der noch...
Das ist gerechtfertigt.
Das zweite Bein, was dann hoffentlich in Zukunft dann auch so ein bisschen zumindest ein Teil des...
Hübsches Logo habt ihr da...
.der Ausgaben abfedert. Das kleine grüne Männchen. Als kleine Geschichte, der erste Pulsar wurde 1967 entdeckt von Jocelyn Bell. Das war eine Physikerin. Weil sie ursprünglich davon ausgegangen sind, weil der so rhythmisch geleuchtet hat, dass das womöglich eine außerirdische Lebensquelle ist, die da im Weltraum rumfunkt. Nochmal, sei noch mal am Rande bemerkt, 1967, Summer of Love und so. Ich bin da geboren. Und sie hat den ersten Pulsaren am Himmel eben LGM 1 für Little Green Men genannt. Und daher der Hintergrund für den Labelnamen.
Alles klar. Ja, dann würde ich sagen, haben wir es, oder? Wollen wir noch was zum Ausklang spielen? Jetzt haben wir schon so schöne Musik gespielt. Dann können wir ja noch mal... Was ist denn hier mit dieser geheimen Tür? Die hatten wir doch vorhin noch in ihrer Ausweise gezogen. Was kann man dazu noch sagen?
Darf ich noch jemanden grüßen?
Wir haben hier freie Formatwahl. Wen willst du grüßen?
Ach, ich grüße die Welt.
Du grüß die Welt. Das ist schön.
Und unseren Stasi 2.0-Schäuble. Und am Freitag haben sie es beschlossen. Endlich die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Wunderbar.
Der Mashup war aber wirklich super. Auf Spreeblick.
Ach ja, das Video von Johnny Häusler. Ja, das gab es auch auf Chaos TV im Übrigen. Im Chaosradio Podcast-Network. Und vielleicht sollte ich hier auch noch mal meinen Plug machen. Das war jetzt Chaosradio Express Nummer 52. Feedback immer gerne gesehen per E-Mail chaosradio.ccc.de. Oder ihr klickt euch auch einfach mal in das neue Blog unter blog.chaosradio.ccc.de. Da wird zu jeder Sendung auch mal kurz was geschrieben. Dann kann man da seinen SEMF ablassen, wenn man mehr drauf steht, dass andere Leute das auch gleich lesen können, was man sozusagen hat. Das soll es ja geben. Ja, und das war es jetzt erstmal wieder für das erste. Vielen Dank, Timor und Don. Das war super. Ich glaube, wir haben das jetzt irgendwie zwei Jahre geplant, diese Sendung. Jetzt ist es endlich mal geklappt. Mal schauen, vielleicht kommen wir auch wieder zusammen, wenn es wieder Interessantes zu berichten gibt, aus der Musikwelt. Das ist ja nicht so häufig hier bei Chaosradio das Thema, aber umso mehr passt es hierher. Jetzt spielen wir noch ein bisschen Musik.